Hey everybody,
what the fuck?
What's up?
This episode of the Joe Rogan experience is brought to you by the dollar Shave
club@dollarshaveclub.com.
You can get razors sent to you for just six bucks for a four pack,
six bucks for the best quality blades you can get.
There's a lot of shit out there when it comes to a razors that people are,
uh,
trying to,
sell you on and promote.
That's a lot of nonsense.
This is,
we need a sharp blade that cuts the fucking hair on your face and all this other
self lubing backscratching laser pointing,
vibrating text messaging.
That's ridiculous for a razor.
You don't need that.
Imagine if your razors really did text messaging.
It's probably happening.
It's on the way someone's probably working on right now and they listened to
this podcast and like you,
Dick,
you've sabotaged my plan on a meet to sabotage your plant dude.
But sorrow slowly.
Look at that.
Look what it says right there.
A dollar month,
$6 a month,
$9 a month.
If you want to get super crafty and go to Ganga Blades,
it's nine bucks in the Middlesex,
but you can get them for a dollar a dollar a month.
I mean,
come on son.
Why did you want to throw money away?
They also have a ton of other cool shit for your bathroom like Dr Carver's,
easy shave butter and one wipe Charlies,
but wipes from men.
I don't know why they have to be for men,
like of a chick comes over your house and uses,
but wipe Charlies.
He said one of those weird things like when a chick uses your deodorant,
I think they need more like a bigger light,
so that's why their dues have bigger bottle.
I guess.
What if you're doing a really large woman,
whatever,
and since dollar shave club.com doesn't waste their money on ridiculous shave
tech,
they charge a fraction of what the big shave companies charge.
Joined the hundreds of thousands of guys who have upgraded to the smarter way to
shave,
shave time,
shave money,
get it to see what they did then get man,
join now dollar shave club.com forward slash Rogan that's dollar shave club.com
forward slash Rogan support this podcast and a great company by going to dollar
shave.com forward slash Rogen and enjoy and enjoy.
Not feeling like a big dummy for buying some self lubing strip on your fucking
razor for an extra 50 bucks.
Holla.
We're also brought to you by legal zoom and legal zoom is a way that you can do
a lot of things that you wouldn't order it ordinarily have to go to a law office
to do.
You could do them all from the comfort of your own home.
You can do them while you're doing other shit like you could conceivably play
Xbox and w in the time that it takes you to respond after you get
killed.
You could fill out forms if you're just a fucking real multitasking nut.
You could have porn on in the background and also legal zoom.
You could probably do it in,
in like if you have a large laptop or if you have good eyes and you could like
do it in a split window format while shaving.
Yes,
while shaving.
Good point.
Mr Antonopoulos.
If you've been thinking about starting your own business,
you can incorporate and form an LLC.
You could do it at legal zoom and you could form an LLC starting at 99 bucks.
You can protect your family with a last will for only 69 bucks.
You can get a living trust power of attorney and more.
Nine out of 10 customers who have used legal zoom would recommend the service to
their friends and family.
That is huge.
You know what else is huge?
They got an a plus from the better business.
Pure.
That's double huge so that way you got to huges because like nine out of 10
you're like,
okay,
who did they ask?
It's like,
you know they say half the people say that the earth is less than 10,000 years
old.
Half the people in this country believe in the biblical version of the Bible.
It's like 40 something a high 40 over 46% shocking but not really.
When you consider the fact that 100% of all people who answer surveys are
idiots,
so half of the idiots think the earth is 10,000 years old,
but for real legit.
Nine out of 10 customers who have actually used legal zoom say that they would
recommend it and the a plus from the better business bureau.
You can't buy that Sun.
Okay?
That only exists if a company is good,
they can help out with trademarks,
copyrights,
patents.
In the past 12 years,
over 2 million Americans have used legal zoom and they've saved ass loads of
money,
big ass loads like the kind of ass loads that you need.
Those those wipes for like large,
large buds.
Anyway,
you get a special discount from listening to this podcast.
Make sure you enter Rogan in the referral box at checkout for more savings.
Legal Zoom is not a law firm,
but if you are in the middle of filling out forms and doing it all by herself
and you fucking panic and you're like,
I'm going to jail,
you can get connected through legal zoom to a third party attorney and they can
provide you with self help services.
That's what legal zoom is really there for,
but the third party attorney thing is gigantic if,
if everything goes awry,
which a word a very rarely used by very,
I feel strong when I use it.
So legal zoom.com use the code word Rogan in the referral box at checkout and
save yourself some money.
Check out legal zoom.com see how they can help you out today.
$139 you can change your name.
Did you ever again,
will you?
My name is Joe Rogan.
No,
someone else could.
I guess you go,
there's more than one of us.
There's a guy in a,
I guess he's in Idaho now,
has the Joe rogan.com
I actually liked it that he has it now because I just know he was,
he was so douchey about it when I wanted to buy it and I'm glad I never did
anyway,
go
to on it.
Dot.
I shouldn't say douchey.
He recognized the value of it and he was playing hardball with me.
Okay.
That's a better way.
It was smart on his side.
He would say I'm Douchey Shit.
All the fucking emails that he probably gets from people.
Black holes and stuff.
Yeah,
all sorts of black dicks.
It's probably got more black dicks and any other Joe Rogan but me
other than me,
I'm like,
I'm a close second.
Do you get a lot of plaques every now and then?
Every now and then in the early days of the podcast when we would bring up black
hawks,
like every 30 30 was a confusion.
There was something that was wrong.
We didn't know what we're talking about.
Black Hawks are just,
we started talking about that.
We're also brought to you by on at.com.
It's o,
n N.
I t if you have not been to on it in a while.
We have a lot of new and fabulous shit like,
uh,
the warrior bar,
which is our new protein bar that is made from organic buffalo meat with no
antibiotics,
no hormones.
It is gluten free with no nitrates.
It is also no MSG,
no soy,
no lactose.
And it is 14 grams of protein in each serving with only four grams of fat and
it's healthy fat.
Does it help?
Bisons are very healthy animals.
Buffalo there,
you know,
you,
there's very few wild buffalo these days,
unfortunately because our great ancestors,
not mine,
but yours.
There were cons.
Mine came from Italy and Ireland.
They had no part in the buffalo slang.
They came here during the 20th century.
But for,
um,
the people that,
uh,
did wipe out the Buffalo Buffalo's are an incredibly healthy and powerful
animals.
They killed a fuck load of them,
but they saved a lot of them too.
Like a lot of people think that buffaloes are extinct.
They're not in Texas.
In fact,
you can,
um,
you can find them at a lot of,
uh,
private hunting ranches.
They have buffaloes and they have a lot of these buffalo farms.
It's like one of the best high protein meats that you can get it.
There is such a crazy animal too.
It's a huge fucking what a,
I mean,
what an amazing animal to perfect animal really to represent the wild west.
It's big giant wild cow with a lion's mane,
you know,
they're so cool.
Anyway,
they're yummy and delicious and we sell their meat at on it.
We also have,
uh,
a wide variety of other healthy foods like organic coconut oil,
which is super healthy for you as well.
Hemp protein powder and we have a new supplement called earth grown nutrients
with earth grow nutrients is,
it's a combination of,
uh,
several different greens,
things that are like super healthy for you and you can add it to protein powers
and it just gives you a little extra boost of nutrients if you're covers your
bases as it were.
If you're not really totally diligent about your diet or if you're a busy person
and you do not have the time to eat many servings of fruits and vegetables a
day,
you can cover a lot of that with a,
a good nutrient blend.
The best way is to get things that come from actual whole foods.
Um,
your body can process synthetic vitamins,
but for sure they're not going to process them as well as actual nutrients that
come from food itself.
And what we use is a combination of,
you know,
essentially what we do with everything else.
We just get the best nutritious things that we can find the best strength and
conditioning equipment we can find.
And with this earth grown nutrients,
we have a lot of really exotic ingredients like Peruvian purple corn,
which is high in antioxidants,
Asai uh,
a lot of other grapes,
grapes,
Skins,
Camou I don't know what that is.
So these are really potent antioxidants.
Mcqueen,
Barry [inaudible],
how would you say that?
My key bury my kid?
This is a few words that I know I've,
I've read that word many,
many times.
I've never even tried to say it.
Um,
the Greens has a,
a combination of wheat grass,
barley grass,
oat grass,
Kale,
Kelp,
Alfalfa,
spirulina.
And what we're just trying to do is give you an option to add to your food,
especially to a protein drink.
That's how I,
that's how I use it,
which just covers a lot of your basis nutritionally.
Excellent stuff.
Really,
um,
really healthy.
It doesn't taste bad and you can throw it right into your food and also has
probiotics in it.
Super good for you.
Um,
use the Codeword Rogan at Ana and you will save 10% off any end.
All supplements,
the fitness equipment,
again,
we sell the best shit we can find,
whether it's kettlebells,
steel,
maces,
steel clubs,
ab wheels,
medicine balls,
we just fought.
Who makes the best equipment,
buy it from them.
That's the way to do it.
Battle ropes.
And we also have kettle bells that we've designed and made ourselves these
Zombie bells and the primal bells.
Those are artistic kettle bells that are also functional.
They're three d designed,
the three d graft them,
uh,
to make sure that they're balanced though,
so that they're not just cool looking,
but they're actually functional.
When you,
uh,
do the kettlebell swings,
they don't,
they're not like off kilter.
What's steel belts?
Steel belts are these bags that are filled with,
um,
these little tiny,
uh,
steel pellets and their,
their heaviest shit.
And you pick them up and you toss them around and throw them.
Really what you should do is get a fucking job,
uh,
farm,
and work doing that all day.
He'd be strong as shit.
You ever tried to arm wrestle at farmer?
They will fuck you up.
That Joel Salitan guy that we had on the podcast,
I bet that old man would fuck me up.
I bet if we arm wrestle,
but I kicked my ass.
They throw hay bales around all day and shit.
But if you don't have time for Hay Bales,
you can,
uh,
get it all done.
Uh,
with,
uh,
the,
Onnit steel bells.
I'm a big fan of the medicine balls.
I've really only worked out with the primal steel belt once and that was when I
was at on it,
but I could see a big benefit in it.
It's also awkward to pick up,
you know,
when you're picking up one of these things,
it's not like picking up a weight shifts and moves around.
And the idea is that it sort of mimics real work.
So it's good for like a conditioning workout as you want to do something that
really like ups,
you're a ups your cardio,
just pick this up and slamming on the ground like 150 times you'd be fucking
exhausted and a bunch of different exercises that you can find with these things
to really,
uh,
it's Kinda cool.
Um,
there's,
we have a video of a bunch of them,
uh,
at on it and we also have a,
a workout section at on it that you can go to for all the different,
um,
uh,
workout equipment like the steel bells,
w kettlebells.
We have a new video that Aubrey and I did where we were talking about our
favorite exercises show,
some alternating cleans and a bunch of different things.
We're going to put these out as as much as possible.
Um,
one important point though,
if you're going to do anything like this,
if you haven't done it,
if you don't have a background in strength and conditioning,
if you don't have a background in exercise,
police start slowly concentrating on the proper form.
If you can film yourself and compare yourself to the way other people are doing
it in videos to make sure that you're doing it correctly,
if you really can,
the the really the best move is to get a trainer.
Get someone who can even just for one workout,
show you how to do it correctly so that you're not fucking yourself up.
You can work out safe and and efficiently with this stuff,
but you really want to make sure that you do it correctly.
To do so.
All right,
go to [inaudible] Dot Com o.
N N.
I t used the Codeword Rogan and save 10% off any and all supplements.
Right.
Andrea [inaudible],
our policies here and we are going to learn more than we did before about the
wonderful powers of the bitcoin
pitch out Rogan experience.
Joe Rogan podcast.
Boom.
How are you sir?
I'm doing great.
Great to have you back again,
man.
It was fun having you on before and a lot of feedback.
A lot of people learned a lot about crypto currencies and the benefits of them,
what's going on,
what were the,
the pushes where the negative things are and put a little balance to a lot of
the negative press that you hear about bitcoin and all these different various
cryptocurrencies in the media because that's literally all I hear.
Yeah,
I mean,
I know people are trading things back and forth,
but you really put it into perspective for us,
especially when you were talking about that what was $150 million transaction as
I was the one that was done through bitcoin.
When you start hearing things like that,
you go,
okay,
well there's some people out there that have some serious fucking money and
they're banking on this.
They're throwing their chips in this corner,
at least some of them to see what's going on.
And I guess the idea is if it's worth $150 million today,
who fucking knows what it would be worth in five years?
That's the big gamble,
right?
Yeah.
Yeah,
it is.
But I,
I,
I think it's important not to look at it as an investment.
Um,
it's so much more interesting as a means of exchange than as a store of value.
It's,
it can do amazing things
in terms of velocity,
just getting money from one place to another,
and it's not about the big movements.
What's even more fascinating as the small moments?
So for example,
I take tips on Twitter and without knowing these people,
they can send me a quarter,
like 25 cents or 10 cents over Twitter instantly.
And you can't even do that with any other payments system because it costs so
much to move money.
And it enables all of these little tiny,
tiny transactions,
um,
and they add up,
you know,
uh,
and it's fun to,
to be able to connect with people that way.
And it's direct unlike say like a paypal situation where you have to give them a
piece of the action.
Yeah.
Not just that.
I mean,
it requires no prior arrangements of any kind.
They don't need to create an account.
I don't need to create an account.
I can just put up my bitcoin address as harvest saving things.
Now if you pay taxes on Bitcoin,
does,
does it,
I mean,
how do you sort it out over the course of a year?
Because the,
the,
the dollar value of it goes up and down.
Yeah.
So how do you figure out,
like when you make taxes,
do you do it at the current rate,
the day you file it?
I mean,
how do you do that?
Um,
well,
we're,
first of all,
we're still trying to figure that out.
It's been about a month since the IRS released some information on how they want
to tax it.
Then they were taxing it like a commodity,
which means capital gains.
So,
um,
you have to account for the price when you bought it and then the price when you
sold it and then look at the difference.
And if you gained you,
you pay tax on capital gains tax on the,
and if you lost you,
you can account for capital losses.
That seems like if people were smart,
they would buy up a shit load of Bitcoin,
then sell like right before and fucking crash the market and then pay their
taxes and then buy and then you'd fucking just keep winning.
Yeah.
The market's big enough that you can't really play those kinds of games.
Dude always think it's going to get complicated.
Is that a possibility?
Could you do that?
And did I just violate the law?
No,
the insider trading never confused
the,
the markets,
the markets pretty huge right now.
So the,
on a daily basis,
uh,
tens of thousands of big coin move around.
So unless you were able to bring a very big amount of air,
you can't really do that.
You can't move these markets artificially.
You'd have to be like some Bill Gates type character to do that and,
and uh,
it would be difficult.
There are far more liquid markets to do that.
You know,
if you want to play games like that,
go play them on s and s and p 500 with front running,
high frequency trading.
That's what's going on.
That's where the big games are being played.
This is small stuff.
They have to make the stock market illegal.
They really do the shits.
Yeah.
You've got a good point too about saying that it's important to not look at it
as an investment because there's some kind of gross about those kinds of
investments.
Like when you find out about somebody got in on a stock early,
like some tech company and then it may like 300 million bucks,
like for no fucking reason.
And then you're like,
wait a minute,
what'd you do?
Where's that money coming from?
I don't get it.
It's way too volatile.
Um,
because it's,
it's a growing technology.
It's a brand new technology is still being tested.
It's way too volatile.
And for the average investor,
that means it's way too risky.
Now there are some investors,
sophisticated investors who have a broad portfolio and who may want to take a
small part of that portfolio and put it into a very high volatility investment
in order to churn some returns out.
But they would do that's in a very,
uh,
knowing exactly how much risk they're taking,
which is a lot and balancing out that risk over big afford a folio.
But your average person,
no,
this is definitely not the kind of thing you want to be playing with.
Use it to do transactions,
hold it for long term playing with this market will only get you burned.
There's this,
there's this real temptation to try to day trade this market.
Uh,
and a lot of people fall for that temptation.
I played with it when I first started with bitcoin.
It was learned that lesson pretty fast.
So you're,
if you're day trading,
exactly.
How would you work that out?
You would say you'd buy up a bunch of bitcoin and then when the price hit a
significant margin,
like if it got to a high enough level you like,
you know what,
I think we just hit the lid,
sell that shit and then you sell it.
Yeah,
buy low,
sell high,
it's cool.
But the problem is you never know where highest and you never know where low
isn't it?
Most people essentially end up falling for the basic psychology of panic and
greed and so they end up actually buying high because of greed and selling low
because of panic and then they end up flipping that equation and losing a lot of
money.
Don't do it.
I mean it's really not worth it.
This is a very interesting technology.
Treating it like a penny stock and trying to,
we make money off it will only get you burned.
Well spoken is a true believer.
I agree with you on that and I think that's cool that you uh,
you stressed that.
What I keep hearing about this Mt.
Gox monkey in the news,
man.
This guy is constantly in the news.
What are they going to do with that dude?
And for folks who don't know,
explain,
if they haven't heard the earlier podcasts,
explain what this,
uh,
Mt Gox situation is.
So first of all,
there's no mountain.
Uh,
here's the interesting story.
This started out as a trading site for a cards for playing cards called magic,
the gathering online exchange,
which everybody knows and no offense to magic the gathering fans,
you guys are fucking dorks.
Okay?
There's no offense,
no offense,
I'm a dork too.
There's a lot of dorkiness too.
A lot of things that I enjoy.
Yeah,
but you guys are fucking serious dorks.
And that was the basis for the original Mt.
Gox site and the domain at least.
Yes.
And then it became this exchange,
one of the biggest exchanges in the world for Bitcoin,
but not secure,
not coded properly,
just a wreck.
Well,
the thing is,
um,
Mt.
Gox is I like to call it a,
which kind of rhymes with Mt.
Gox.
Um,
because it really is just an acronym.
It's not a,
um,
it started off as a trading site and it offered something really important and
valuable.
In the early days of Bitcoin when you were trading locally among individuals,
there was no price discovery mechanism.
There was no way to figure out how much a big coin was worth because there was
no liquid market.
So,
you know,
if I,
if I bought some bitcoin from you,
we have to figure out what price we were both comfortable with and maybe we'd
ask somebody else to,
well,
how much did you buy it for?
And that's how you discover the price,
right?
Because if there isn't a really big liquid market,
you don't know what the prices,
was it more stable then?
No,
it was a,
it was a even more volatile because keep in mind at the time,
bitcoin was trading for,
uh,
thousands of a penny a or pennies.
So you could basically buy a thousand bitcoin for a dollar and you're really
tastes
wow.
And that would be worth what,
like a hundred grand now or something close to it.
All right,
that wouldn't be worth half a million dollars.
Now.
Half a million.
Well,
wow.
I'm so behind the price.
Yeah.
What is the price of 501?
No.
Oh,
it's 500 bucks now.
Yeah.
Wow.
I was way off as the thing goes.
300 something.
I,
yeah,
I really wasn't sure between down what's the lowest it's been like in recent
times.
Um,
so last year,
this time it jumped from about a hundred to two 66 and then dropped again down
to 50.
Um,
so at some point last year it was 50,
and then,
uh,
in the meantime it's 500.
Then it went all the way up to about a thousand,
maybe 1100 on some markets,
and then it dumped all the way down to 800.
Stayed there for a bit,
and then it dumped all the way down to 500.
And then it had a brief period flirting with three 70,
and then it went back up.
I mean,
so here's what's happening.
Um,
every couple,
every few weeks.
Um,
China started back in April of last year.
The China market opened up in,
oh,
sorry.
In November of last year,
the China market opened up and everyone's like,
yeah,
China's in bit coin to the moon.
The price shut up.
Ah,
interesting.
And then China said,
we're thinking of banding it and the price crashes and then,
but maybe we won't baton it to the price rises,
but maybe we'll ban it's and then the price crashes and we've been playing this,
is it band?
Is it not band?
Does it pans?
Is it not band for the last five months and it's been a rollercoaster and in the
end or it really doesn't matter.
I mean,
so for folks who don't know what we're talking about,
this Mt Gox thing was this online exchange that it turned out someone somehow,
whether it was an inside job or not,
someone somehow was stealing money to the tune of hundreds of millions
took all of it.
The bitcoin took all of the money and they change 100% of it.
Well like 85 90% of it.
Oh my God.
So someone somewhere stole an insane amount of money,
but you're not hearing about some wild man hunt to get to that money.
If it was like,
there was a guy named Lee Marie all right.
And Lee Marie was a mixed martial arts fighter from the UK who is a real crazy
man.
He was like as white as they come.
He was like a real live version of a character from a Guy Ritchie movie guy was
nuts.
He fought in the UFC.
It was a really good fighter to fought Anderson Silva and cage rage.
I mean high level guy.
Um,
and he was also a fucking thug,
like super legit criminal and he was a part of a huge multimillion dollar bank
heist where they came in with fucking ski masks and bulletproof vests and,
and you know,
high powered rifles and machine guns though the full deal,
like full black ops,
like,
like a movie.
And they,
I mean they have the security cameras with these guys and then somehow or
another they all got nabbed.
And uh,
this guy,
Lee Marie was a,
one of the ones they chased after the hardest.
He went to Morocco and he was hiding there and they got arrested there for,
he got arrested there for like kidnapping someone a beaten him like after he did
the bank job.
I mean this guy's a fucking maniac,
right?
Uh,
but the point is there was a fucking man hunt.
It was all over the newspapers in the UK.
It was everywhere.
They were going after these motherfuckers.
And it seems to me like the amount of money that was stolen in Mt.
Gox is commensurate
to this or it's bigger,
bigger,
but,
but here's,
here's the,
is it really bigger?
Yeah.
I think how much are they?
How much was the UK Bank?
Let me find out.
Nobody knows exactly how much is gone at Cox,
but it's somewhere between six and 800 million.
All my God,
it is bigger.
But here's the thing,
Bernie Madoff stole $20 billion,
20 billion with a B and there wasn't a man hunt there because the real truth is
that if you want to rob a bank,
what you do is you go get a banking license.
Thank you for all of the bank using a keyboard instead of a machine gun.
No one starts a man hunt that way.
Um,
that's the modern way of doing bank heists and,
and that's the way that doesn't get you a shot and nets you the biggest return.
Well,
when you're a crazy criminal though,
and you don't know how to work keyboard fat,
well,
I mean,
you gotta be Italy.
You gotta be El three,
three t,
right?
Pull that shit off.
So this Mt Gox thing.
Someone somewhere has stolen,
let's put a number on it.
You say $800 million.
No,
nobody knows that.
I was just saying $100 million.
It's somewhere between five and eight,
I think.
Let's just say it's $100 million.
Several hundred million dollars derivative and say it's $100 million from the
current at the current bitcoin price.
Yeah.
If someone stole a hundred fucking million dollars worth of money,
like if $100 million worth of diamonds went missing,
what a man hunt there would be for that,
but something like that or,
or stolen and go missing in the banking system.
And in government affairs all the time.
And there was no man hunt.
I mean this is fairly typical of what happens.
These are white collar.
It's about
records and forensic accounting and analysis and drawn out cases where they
tried to figure out what happened.
The bottom line is every year about a hundred or more banks fail spectacularly
and the money disappears.
And this was just another bank failure.
It really had very little to do with bitcoin.
It was a bank failure of the very traditional kinds.
This was not a system that's used bitcoin to protect its security.
It was a systems that collected all of the bitcoin and one big account,
uh,
and then lost that.
So it's essentially,
um,
the account was robbed in the account,
just happened to be holding bitcoin.
Yeah.
And actually the dollar dollars dollar's had gone to
the currency accounts in the banks were also,
um,
how much was that?
Their dollars?
Some dollars missing.
I don't know.
It was a lot less money to man.
It was a few million.
It was a few million or maybe tens of millions,
but,
but it wasn't like hundreds.
So,
yeah,
here's the thing,
like,
um,
you have a bitcoin wallet,
right?
That means you control the keys.
And that's the essence of Bitcoin is that individual's control them.
They don't have a bank,
they don't have their money in a bank where someone else has custody of it and
then they just have a little IOU note that says you have this much in the bank
and maybe we'll give it to you when you come to was my next question.
So Gox did not have individual account bitcoin accounts for the users.
They took the bitcoin and then put it all into one of their own accounts and,
and managed it.
So they took it out all of the security of each person having their own keys and
instead collected all the money in one vague wallet.
Wow,
that's crazy.
Why would they do that?
What's the benefit of that?
Well,
um,
there's this instinct to implement the same types of centralized banking
institutions.
And here's the thing.
When you have that much money under the control of an individual on an
organization,
society then builds all of these regulatory institutions because they figured
out that when you do that,
those institutions,
those organizations,
those individuals steal the money again and again.
When you put one person in charge of the money,
they steal the money.
That's what power corrupts.
Absolute power corrupts absolutely,
and there is no more powerful corrupting influence than money.
So when you have people who have millions in their control,
bad things happen.
Someone just fucks off with it.
They just figured out a way to do it right or they're sloppy with their security
and somebody else robs them.
But in either case,
all of the banking regulations we have are to stop the fact that individual's
control too much money from stealing that money.
Bitcoin is a different solution.
The idea is instead of collecting all the money in one big bucket,
you have each user controlling their own money.
You don't put it in a bank,
you don't concentrate the risk.
And that way you don't need all of
these elaborate controls because you don't take the control of the money away
from the individual.
You leave it in the hands of the individuals.
Well,
Mt.
Gox took it away of the control of the individuals,
but then didn't have any of the regulatory institutions that we traditionally
have in banking,
so they weren't using the bitcoin security and there weren't using the
traditional banking regulations and audits to protect them.
They were in this gray area in between where they had all of the control over
the money and none of the protections.
What the fuck?
That's ridiculous.
That is a vending competence as well.
I mean like really,
really bad management of really bad coding.
Really bad technology use.
Just gross and competence of an unbelievable scale.
I mean you'd think with all of that money they'd hire some competent people,
but the incompetent started at the top.
Well,
you look at the guy at the top and has dumped fat face.
Look at that fucking dummy.
Look at that.
That guy's never been good at anything.
I'll tell you why right now,
God was a dump fat face like that.
I said,
if you have a dumb fat face and you're smart,
I apologize.
Apologize Right now.
I have a dumb face to,
oh,
he plays magic.
The gathering.
Yeah.
Well he doesn't just play it.
He owns a fucking online exchange.
Well,
he actually bought it from someone else.
How much do you pay for it?
I,
I don't know.
I mean,
there was some kind of,
this goes way back in the early days,
but here's the thing,
Mark Kurt Palace to the guy you just showed in that photo,
let's call big fat face.
Can we cut?
Sure.
Um,
so I don't,
I don't know him personally.
I've never met him,
but he provided a really critical service at a time when bitcoin desperately
needed it.
He provided a market where people could buy and sell bitcoin in a transparent
way.
And for the first time you had bitcoin pricing,
you could figure out how much a bitcoin was worth because there were lots of
people trading it.
And therefore the price that they settled on over thousands of trades was priced
discovery.
You,
you need that to the market to function.
So now you had a price and for many years the Mt Gox price was the price of
bitcoin.
Um,
all right,
so we'll stop calling them big fat face,
but then let's call poor bastard.
Okay.
So poor bastard starts out good.
It starts out good,
everything's going great.
He helps out a lot of people by letting them establish a price.
Yeah.
Which we made a huge difference for bitcoin.
I mean there was the first time you had a liquid market where people could
actually trade knots just face to face,
but,
but could exchange of various currencies for bitcoin.
And that was incredibly important without,
without Mt.
Gox
so he's essentially,
this is just a symptom of a growing market that he just wasn't prepared for.
Like as if like here's a perfect example.
If I was running something,
okay,
I'm a dummy.
Like when it comes to computers,
I'm a real dummy.
So if I was running some sort of online exchange and somehow or another it
started trading bitcoin and then I saw,
started seeing hundreds of millions of dollars,
I would,
I would have to bring people in.
I would have to bring in like financial experts,
coding experts.
I have to try to anywhere,
any experts,
man,
I'm busy as fuck man.
I wouldn't probably do it right.
I would probably fuck it up just the way poor bastard fucked it up.
Yeah.
So can't really blame him except he's got his finger out.
Well,
here's the thing.
Fuck you back buddy.
There's a chance,
you know,
we don't know if this was just gross waste management or also fraud.
I'm not gonna go as far as say poor bastard because there's a good chance that
he heard,
he heard a lot of people very badly and there's a,
there's a chance that he was culpable.
Big Fat face,
you will find out.
But,
but at the same time,
it's a classic story of someone who,
um,
was in a situation that was way over their head and then they tried to handle it
without asking for help.
And then it snowballed and they tried to cover up some mistakes by trying to
cover up,
by making bigger mistakes and then bigger mistakes and then bigger mistakes.
How did you try to cover it up?
Well,
once,
uh,
so some money was taken in an earlier incident from the system and then I think
he tried to cover up the lack of money by essentially generating more fees from,
from the customers.
Um,
and you know,
paying for the previous loss by bringing in new customers and trying to stay
ahead of the loss,
which by the way,
you've seen,
we've seen this again and again,
it's a Bernie Madoff movie.
Essentially it was running a mini pyramid scheme,
right.
And,
and Pyramid Scheme pyramid schemes are very rarely intentional.
Nobody starts out to Sam going to run a pyramid scheme.
What happens is they take a bat,
they lose on that bet and then they tried to cover up the fact that they lost by
bringing in more people and the like,
as long as I stay ahead of this,
it's not going to bite me.
And then it gets bigger and bigger.
We saw that with that trader in,
um,
I think it was a one of the Swiss banks,
who was,
who was essentially trading bigger and bigger bets in order to cover up previous
mistakes and getting further out until eventually it all collapsed.
And we've seen this happen again and again.
It's really trying to cover up an early mistake by making a bigger mistake.
And then it snowballs.
Well,
I have seen legit pyramid schemes.
I had a guy who was a coach at a boxing gym,
tried to talk me into a pyramid scheme.
I mean he was describing it in the dumbest way ever.
He was describing a pyramid scheme.
He's like a bunch of people put the money in and then a,
hey,
I got money.
Oh,
that's how I got these rooms on my truck.
And I was like,
what are you doing?
He's like,
you,
you invest,
you know,
you put money in the new people come in and then,
you could take money out of the new people coming.
I go,
it's a pyramid scheme.
Do you know what you're saying?
He's like,
he didn't know what a pyramid scheme was.
Well,
um,
I learned that lesson in seventh grade.
Yeah,
it's a very,
my school buddies were running a little um,
candy permit scheme,
a candy Perez.
Basically it was candy was um,
what do you call it?
Like the,
we had one of those uh,
cantinas where you
could buy doughnuts and things like that.
So it was kind of like a doughnut.
It's a pyramid scheme based on the school canteen that wears.
Um,
but,
but they actually drew it on the,
on the blackboard as a,
as an airplane where you sit at the front and then two people sit behind you and
then four people sit behind you.
And then it was kind of like,
it was called the airplane and it was basically a permit scheme that some kid
had heard from somewhere and introduced into the class.
And then our teacher sat us down and said,
this is what a pyramid scheme is and this is why you're not allowed to do this
in the school.
Does he does it to see what you'd want to like find out where that guy is now of
even if he was doing that with candy back then when I can creep in of Avon,
I would like to send him a thank you card or a real life financial education.
I mean what a valuable lesson to learn early and then not fall for it again.
That is so true.
Especially because you got to see it in an actual form,
not like some sort of abstract lesson that's someone's teaching.
You got to see it actually play out.
PLO 800 people in the school.
It fizzles out pretty quickly.
You run out of soccer,
soccer really,
really fast.
Right.
So it only lasted
I think about two weeks before the whole thing came crashing down,
but,
but it was a fantastic demonstration in real life in a closed controlled
environments and the only losses were really to the collapse of the local donuts
economy.
That's funny.
My,
the guy who came up to me,
I explained to him that it was a pyramid scheme and he still tried to sell me on
it.
He's like,
Yo,
no,
I'm telling you you should do it.
You should put your money.
I'm like,
what are you saying?
Like did I just explained to you what this is is a pyramid scheme.
You know what a pyramid scheme is?
Like people get ripped off,
hey,
you're not going to get ripped off.
Okay,
I gotta go.
Yeah,
but this was a pyramid scheme almost like just to cover up in competence and
then it sort of snowballed like a lie that you couldn't help and then that lie,
you might have got a bunch of their lives to cover that.
La and then La.
Well,
keep in mind,
I'm speculating,
this is based on the information we have right now.
We've seen that there were a couple of failures early on and then it seems like
he was trying to cover up for those.
We don't know yet.
Right.
This is only going to come out.
He was a part of it as well.
Right.
We don't know how much was stolen by outside people.
Um,
he certainly did try to cover losses,
but we don't know if those losses occurred because he lost a keys to,
to,
to bitcoin and essentially lost the money or if it was stolen or if it was
embezzled or if it was whatever.
We don't know.
And there's now parallel prosecutions happening both in Japan and in the United
States to find the answers to that.
Here's the interesting thing.
We're going to find out the answers to that because Bitcoin uses a public ledger
and there's forensic evidence sprinkled in the bitcoin transaction leisure that
allows us to track exactly what happens.
This is the most transparent financial system.
So we're going to get some really interesting answers so we'll be able to find
out who has it.
We,
um,
not really,
but we're going to be able to find out what happened and when it happens.
I mean,
you'd just happened when it happened,
but you can't find out where it went and you can't track it.
Right.
Can,
you can't track Ip addresses through Bitcoin.
You can or can't,
cannot,
cannot.
No,
you can't home.
So there's no way to figure out where that stuff went,
where the bitcoins went.
Not really.
But you can see when it went out,
all of accounts that wouldn't known to be controlled by Gox and,
and so you can rebuild a timeline.
Here's the other thing that's not going to happen.
Mt.
Gox didn't get bailed out.
Um,
Mt.
Gox didn't get 0% interest loans from a central bank in order to pretend they're
solvent when they're not.
Mt Gox didn't make deals with other banks to cover up their losses by
collateralizing them in CDOS.
Mt.
Gox didn't get to acquire some of the failing banks,
add them to their asset sheets and for them,
pretend that they were not failing.
Mt.
Gox didn't gets to bail in all of the customers of bitcoin across the entire
economy.
Mt.
Gox didn't get too hyper inflate the currency in order to save themselves,
but destroy the economy.
No.
All of those things happened after 2008.
Hold on a second.
What you're saying sounds exactly like what went on with our economy.
Yeah.
Oh,
law.
Wait a minute.
Does this guy in trouble?
Oh yeah.
Yeah.
Where is he?
It,
he might,
he might be,
he might be one of the few examples of banker's going to jail.
Really?
Yes.
Which doesn't happen very often.
It really happens in two cases.
It happens.
So the two,
two small fish,
uh,
who can't get out of the book of Justice,
him,
the look of justice,
I love it.
Or A,
it happens for those who steal money from very,
very rich people.
Can't do that.
Bernie Madoff didn't steal.
I didn't steal millions of mortgages from people.
No,
he stole money from very,
very rich people.
You can't get away with that.
Uh,
I see.
Um,
do you think that,
is this guy in hiding?
Like is he,
no,
he's in,
he's in Japan right now.
There's a extradition requests.
They know where he is.
I believe so,
yeah.
How has no one killed him?
I mean,
you would think that this guy with hundreds of millions of dollars,
like every step that God takes,
you must be looking over his shoulder.
Does he still look like that?
I would shave my head and grow big tape beard.
Yeah,
free.
First of all,
Japan,
Japan has very,
very few,
very low incidences of violent crime.
Uh,
there's not too many weapons around.
The culture is not like that.
And then the other culture,
which is a well geeks like me,
I mean,
you know,
um,
I am trying to attack someone and caused them harm.
I'd have to reach for an asthma inhaler four times in the process of committing
a crime.
But it seems like a guy,
like you could figure out a way to code an APP for your phone.
The controls are drone that shoots
missiles.
I mean,
I would,
I would think you'd see people like you'd be the worst people to fuck.
Not motivated enough.
I Dunno,
but you're not motivated.
No,
but you didn't lose hundreds of millions of dollars is cat.
Like what if you had $100 million in that 800 plus whatever it was that
disappeared if $100 million,
you know,
whatever Poe plus or minus was all yours.
You,
it'd be fucking bloody furious.
And there are a lot of people who are very upset and very hurt by this
situation.
And a lot of people who lost a lot of money,
including a,
it had a ripple effect.
You've got to realize that many bitcoin businesses had money in accounts there.
Mm.
So that loss then affected the cashflow of,
of other bitcoin businesses that suffered and charities,
many charities that lost money and,
and Mt.
Gox
oh wow.
So a business like say like a one that I keep hearing about is tiger direct
tiger directors is a pretty huge
pewter company.
overstock.com both of those hues.
Bitcoin.
Yeah.
Um,
that's interesting.
Overstock,
keep hearing good things about overstock.
Yeah.
They generally don't have much exposure because they don't,
they,
here's the thing,
people who are using it as an exchange,
so when you have excess bit coin,
move it in their self,
a dollars,
move the dollars out.
It just in and out.
Right.
The first is storing the bitcoin there as a wallet,
uh,
and giving them full control of that and just leaving piles of bitcoin there.
Those were the ones most affected and some of the day traders who had to have
piles of bitcoin there so that they could trade very quickly.
Those were very affected.
But people who just moved money in and out,
you know,
maybe they lost that day's take.
And,
and if you look at it,
merchants like the ones you mentioned,
uh,
they don't leave stashes of bitcoin around.
They're going to exchange that pretty quickly.
They're going to move out of the exchange if they're smart.
So they exchange it for dollars and then they move.
Okay.
Now,
um,
how much can you actually store on your phone or your phone?
Like if you wanted a store,
$1 million with the Bitcoin,
could you put it on your phone?
You could store $1 trillion worth of bitcoin.
You could store whatever you want.
I mean,
there is no one in case you lose your phone,
Jesus fucking Christ.
You'd have your phone connected to your wrist and all wrapped around your waist
with chains.
Yeah,
that would be a supremely dumb and bad idea to do.
But you can't make backups of Bitcoin,
which you can't do with regular money.
You can have multiple copies,
you can encrypt those copies.
So you can do a lot of things to protect yourself against loss.
Can you have what you call it?
Like can you have like your main wallet and then like have like a sub wallet
that hasn't completely different like pass code or a way to get in?
Yeah,
that's right.
Yeah.
You can actually make a whole tree structure of wallets.
So why didn't like this,
this company,
this mk or whatever it's called to God,
why didn't they just have a shitload of sub wallets,
you know,
to protect each individual user instead of putting it into one.
Is that,
that that goes to the gross and competence I was talking about earlier.
So that's not how they,
there are are the businesses who also have custodial account
over bitcoin and they implement very smart systems to segregate bitcoin.
So for example,
on a daily basis,
they will sweep 95 to 98% of the bitcoin off into a wallets.
The require three out of six people to come together.
To unlock them with the key separated on separate devices.
Um,
and those systems are very difficult to break,
right?
Because you need collusion between multiple people and that protects both from
external theft,
but it also protects from internal compromise,
a malicious insider or um,
embezzlement fraud even by the CEO sometimes.
So there are ways to get around this.
You can have good security practices and all of those good security practices
were completely ignored by Mark Karpeles.
So he's a fuck head no matter what.
Yeah.
So the question really now is gross incompetence or fraud and we don't know,
but in,
in either case it's bad.
It hurt a lot of people,
but in the end it had nothing to do with bitcoin.
It was a classic bank failure of the traditional kind that it was the result of
the fact that they fell in a gray area where they didn't have the protections of
bitcoin and they didn't have the regulations of a regular bank.
So this guy lives in Japan.
Did he move to Japan when the shit hit the fan or was he there the entire time?
He was there the entire time.
So he's always lived in Japan.
That's where Mt.
Gox was based.
Yes.
Ah,
interesting.
Okay.
Mt.
Gox I love it.
And so Mt.
Gox now is insolvent.
Is it done?
I mean there was some
trying to do some kind of structured thing and then,
uh,
I think it was four or five days ago,
the Japanese authorities decided to decline and forced them into liquidation.
So they are now done and tick boxes over.
The one thing we can say about Mt Gox is that they can no longer hurt
anyone else.
That's the good thing.
Now,
this gentleman who runs it or ran it,
he's walking on the streets.
He goes places.
He's just like a regular guy.
Do they follow him?
I have no idea.
I think he's on,
he's under indictment.
I don't,
I don't know what his status is.
So He's under indictment from America and from Japan.
Correct.
There's,
and there's a warrant for him to come to the states.
Okay.
So,
um,
it's not as gangster as if he robbed a bank and held it up with guns.
Like they're not,
they're not going after him with like a swat team and dragging them back,
but most likely he's fucked.
We'll see.
Yeah,
most likely.
Yeah.
I mean I,
I would be surprised if he doesn't face some kind of a serious consequences.
You weren't that concerned though about this in the overall scheme of things for
bitcoin.
You thought this was just sort of a bump in the road and that eventually it
would be overwhelmed by the sheer positive benefits of cryptocurrencies?
Well,
I mean I think the,
the thing is that it didn't really affect bitcoin itself.
It wasn't a weakness of bitcoin.
It was in fact a very strong arguments
for why you need to decentralize financial institutions.
Cause when you centralize them,
they failed in exactly this fashion.
That's,
that's what we're trying to change about financial services.
Make them more decentralized,
diffuse the power so it can be corrupted and,
and compromised.
Um,
there are going to be more,
I'll tell you right now,
there are going to be more bank failures Bolson bitcoin and of course as they
happen every single year by the hundreds,
they're going to be bank failures in every currency including bitcoin.
There are going to be CEOs who run away with the money until we implement better
solutions to control the power.
So for example,
if you've got a startup and they raising money in Bitcoin,
you don't give all of the keys to one person use,
you split them among multiple people.
So that one part,
because the person you think you know who's your Cherice partner in this venture
and you've known all your life and your childhood friends,
um,
when they have access to a couple million dollars,
they change,
people change their dramatically and radically affected by money.
And then all you need is a precipitating event,
an illness in the family,
a crisis,
you know,
a,
a bad thing happening to that person.
And they will grab that money and run.
People make very poor decisions
and they still tell you the,
hey man,
I needed it.
Yeah.
Right?
And they'll rationalize it or they'll make a mistake day trading and making a
loss or losing some of the money and then trying to cover it up,
whatever it is that,
you know,
my advice to bitcoin companies is when you're starting out,
look at the person sitting next to you and do not assume you can trust them,
assumes that people are fallible and then put in place controls so that no
single person can run away with money and then you're going to be much more
secure and everybody will be able to be above board.
David Seaman who was on the podcast last week had a really interesting take on
big coin that I thought it was kinda funny.
Um,
he was saying that if,
if bank,
like Bank of America for [inaudible],
if they were smart,
they would get involved in bitcoin.
It was like you already have this established name brand,
like cryptocurrencies are going to be here.
They're,
they're,
they're here to stay.
This is his take.
He was like,
why wouldn't you capitalize on the name brand that you've already built in on
and get in on the mark and quick get it on it now and the early days and
established like that Bank of America like still has like a footing in in this
as well as in regular money.
And he was like,
it would be a really wise investment.
I think you're going to see that happening.
Um,
in short time really,
um,
we saw this with the Internet,
which was at first the telecommunications companies fought tooth and nail.
They could not believe that a decentralized packet switch network like the
Internet would deliver quality,
voice and quality video.
They wanted to build highly controlled and structured networks.
Um,
and they tried to fight it because it,
it threatens and long distance market,
which was very lucrative.
It threatened many other markets.
Today,
three quarters of all international calls happen on Skype.
Three quarters,
three quarters.
That's,
that's a market that a few,
you know,
a two decades ago was,
uh,
15 $20 billion market and disappeared.
Um,
and essentially they had to restructure operations.
Now they made up for it.
The smart ones became very good as Internet service providers and created whole
new businesses.
The replace those lost revenues.
So,
so what happened there is you have these telecom companies trying to fight it
until some of the smaller ones,
some of the ones that don't have solid,
entrenched positions and can't take advantage of size.
Think,
you know what,
maybe I'm going to cut off from this herd and go play with that bitcoin a bit.
And as soon as that starts happening,
there's almost a stampede because everybody tries to rush into it.
That's what happens with telecommunications.
The smaller providers started peeling off from the herd and instead of fighting
it,
they started trying to build service providers.
Uh,
so it's really just a matter of who runs first,
right?
Someone's going to start running and then,
and then the herd breaks apart because until the first one breaks,
everyone's like,
well,
we were too serious for this bitcoin stuff.
And they're looking over their shoulder trying to make sure that everybody else
is also staying away from it.
But eventually the market dynamic changes.
So it's just
essentially,
it's just human nature,
like with human nature this to certain rules that are just always going to be
into place,
play hard to get and follow the leader.
Those are two big ones.
Yeah.
And bitcoin threatens some business structures within the banking industry.
It May,
it's going to make it difficult for them to charge exorbitant fees to do
international wire transfers when you can do it cheaper.
Just like if you have Skype,
you can't justify $3 a minute long distance calls and,
but at the same time the smart bankers are looking at this and their thing.
Yeah.
But if we have a cheap,
efficient,
secure payment system,
we can build some really interesting things on top of that and create whole new
businesses that are very competitive that can actually give us a lead.
So we,
oh,
Alix run the heard the,
you know,
disruption in a competitive market is actually very,
um,
very enticing to the,
to the second and third tier players because they don't have an advantage.
They're too small to compete against the big guys.
But if they see this disruptive technology,
I think,
well,
maybe if I hit your ride on that I'm going to overtake everybody.
Um,
and you know,
I can be the blockbuster or I can be the Netflix,
I can be the tower records,
or I can be the iTunes.
And we've seen this happen in technology racist before.
Yeah.
That's fascinating how people,
some people just don't want to buck the trends they did.
They don't want to go along with the flow of things or they want to buck the
trends.
They want to somehow or another figure out a way where,
you know,
they can prove everybody else wrong and VHS is making a comeback and,
renting movies still valid.
You know,
there's,
there's a lot of those fuckers out there that just won't let it go.
Radio companies change is scary.
Yeah.
That's scary.
But that's,
that's a,
that's the nature of the beast.
Especially today.
We were involved in the craziest time for change.
The world's ever known.
Yeah.
Um,
there at the moment,
being on the top of it and industry,
especially an industry that's involved in technology is a very precarious
position.
You know,
if you talk to,
um,
Kodak a decade ago,
do you think they would,
they would realize that suddenly it's the largest vendor or manufacturer of
cameras in the world would be a telephone company.
Nokia,
within three years became the world's largest maker of cameras and suddenly the
entire industry changed.
Right.
And how do you compete against that?
They're not even in your industry.
They just came out of left field.
It's like you're suddenly the horse buggy manufacturer and forward is taking
your business and you never expected that was going to happen.
Well,
Nokia has a camera phone now,
a windows phone that is some insane amount of pixels.
It's like 40 fucking megapixels or something,
something crazy.
41 41 megapixel says Jamie,
Jamie's on top of that shit.
41 fucking megapixels on a phone.
I mean,
this thing I think has the note three,
I think it has 12 or something.
No,
it's better than that.
Are you familiar with Moore's law?
Yes.
So,
so for,
for your listeners to Moore's law,
it was created by Gordon Moore processors,
right?
Processing speed and yeah,
and what he said was that he estimated that because of the way silicon works
every 18 months,
the speed of a computer with double or the price would drop by half.
And that has been true now for more than 25 years.
Wow.
And,
and that thing then plays out in camera megapixels,
in storage on SD cards in the size of the,
of your smartphone,
in the,
a number of sensors you can put into the smartphone.
And it's battery.
Battery life is the one that's lagging behind.
And it's the main thing that's holding back this technology.
Moore's law also applies to things like bitcoin.
It also applies to networks like the Internet.
And what it means is that if you're in an industry that's established and
suddenly you have a competitor that's coming at you with the power of Moore's
law,
you better watch out because you're in,
it's not a matter of whether you will be able to compete in a decade.
It's a matter of whether your industry will still exist in a decade,
right?
Yeah.
Isn't that fascinating?
That whole industries can just vanish hundred and 50 years of Kodak and then
suddenly film doesn't exist,
God and the decade.
Do you remember when you used to have to pay money for long distance?
Long distance calls don't exist.
You can call New York right now and your home phone and it's regular call on
your cell phone.
It's totally normal.
Like if you used to call long distance on a cell
phone,
it was an exorbitant amount of money.
Saturday afternoons,
London,
painful.
And when I was a student I would go there with a stack of coins that was
probably about $10 worth in today's money.
I would sit in a payphone and my family would know what time I was going to call
coordinated.
I'd call in,
they'd be a line of 15 relatives sitting,
standing behind the phone on the Athens sides and Avi.
Hi Mom.
I love you very much.
Hi Dad.
I love you very much,
Hasis.
It's all awesome.
Okay,
next ants,
ants,
Maria.
And you know London's awesome.
And I'm stuffing coins as fast as I can into this pay phone.
And then you know,
four or five minutes later,
$10 down the drain and I've said hello to the entire family and that's all I
could afford.
That was my experience.
And now you could Skype for hours for free and not crazy.
You could look at a video of you
each other talking to each other through your laptop for free.
Wow.
Fascinating,
fascinating times.
And when you put it in that kind of a perspective,
you really sort of understand that change.
They just,
the ability that we have to reach out to each other is just unprecedented in
human history.
It's never been even remotely close to what it is now.
I saw somebody walking down the street the other day,
skyping with someone while they were walking down the street and they were
talking while they're walking down the street.
They're like,
yeah,
so we're gonna,
blah,
blah.
And then the other person's on the other end.
I'm looking at their phone.
I'm like,
this is crazy.
They're doing it through a cell phone connection.
I'm doing that all the time now.
Yeah.
Walking down the street through a cell phone connection,
streaming video back and forth to each other.
It's amazing.
Amazing.
What do you think about things like,
is there a reason why apple doesn't have any apps where you can exchange
bitcoin?
They have some bitcoin monitoring apps,
correct?
They've,
they've basically banned any apps that allow you to run a wallet to do
transactions.
Is there a reason for that?
I mean,
is there like,
can you find a lug a logical if you try to take devil's advocate?
Yeah,
there's,
there's three or four reasons and I can give you them from the obvious to the,
to the cynical and paranoid.
Um,
first of all,
I think they are worried about this strange technology that they don't know
anything about and they're worried about what kind of reputation hit they'll
take if one of these apps is compromised,
um,
and causes their customers to lose money.
Right.
I'm more worried then Google who allow all of these applications on Google play.
So it's not a legal thing because Google has lawyers too and they're quite happy
to allow bitcoin applications and apple does not like it.
That's the obvious answer.
Um,
there's another thing when whenever you spend money on buying an APP or buying
something inside the nap,
apple takes like 30%
mm.
So their own payment system through the APP store and iTunes and all of these
things generates an enormous amount of revenue because they take a very big cut
of these things.
If you could put a wallet in a phone,
then you could also put a wallet in an APP.
Then you could also do bitcoin transactions in an APP.
Then why give apple 30% cut if you can just bypass them and do all the payments
through that?
That's ultimately going to be apples demise though.
I mean if you look at it,
you want to talk about like people that had a grip on a market and then it
slowly slipped away.
Apple had an enormous chunk of the smartphone market just a few years ago.
I mean,
they had the majority of it now 80 something percent of the smart phones or
android phones.
That's crazy.
I mean that,
that's quite amazing.
And the technology has surpassed them.
Now you have several choices with android phones that are waterproof,
big giant ones as Sony Experia you could throw it underwater for a fucking half
an hour,
like five feet of water for half an hour.
I mean the,
the galaxy s five,
the new one,
water resistant.
You could take a shower with it and listen to music.
He,
you could put a fucking stuff it in your underwear and literally shower with the
thing on.
I mean,
fingerprint sensors,
they had them first on iPhones,
but now Samsung galaxies,
a s five has a fucking heart rate monitor.
I mean,
there's,
they're just,
they're ahead of the curve.
Like the,
the android phones aren't playing catch up with apple anymore.
Now they're bypassing him.
And I wonder if that's going to happen with things like iTunes,
the exchanges,
things.
Right now it's convenient to use iTunes.
But once I switched over to Android,
um,
I found a thing called double twist where you could send your music to your
phone,
you can use iTunes with this thing.
And also I found Amazon Mp3,
which is just as easy to use,
if not easier.
Then iTunes.
I changed as a horrible application.
I can't stand it.
It's like you put it on your Mac and you get a pinwheel every time you click on
anything,
especially if you have a large collection,
it's,
and it hasn't really changed or improved much at all.
Um,
but it does ask you to accept the terms and conditions every time you sneeze.
Uh,
so you have to click on that thing.
It's like,
listen,
apple,
I've accepted the terms.
I haven't read them,
no one's read them,
but I accept them.
I accept them forever.
Just give me a checkbox that says from now on,
until the end of time,
I accept,
I accept.
Please.
Yeah.
Do a retina scan every time I look at your APP,
as soon I'm accepting.
Um,
I like iTunes for some things.
I use it still to buy movies.
I use it on my laptop exclusively.
I use it on my home computer exclusively.
Like if I'm buying music,
I buy my music and I buy it off through that.
But on my phone it's just as easy to buy it through Amazon.
It's very simple.
It's not,
it's not like some new thing you have to learn.
Same process.
You search a genre search an artist,
oh I wanted to buy like we were in the green room the other day if the Orlando
hard rock,
me and Joey Diaz and Joey Diaz goes on this epic rant about led Zeppelin as led
Zeppelin one cause there was a poster on the wall that I took a picture of and I
put it up on my Instagram and it was the first tour poster from led Zeppelin in
1968 69 and we were like,
could you fucking imagine what that must have been like to experience like
Zeplin for the first time?
Like back then,
like any jelly was going off about how it blew people away.
So listening to him,
I get inspired.
I go to my phone as he's talking within like 10 seconds,
I type led Zeppelin in the search.
Boom,
it's downloading.
Three seconds after that,
Bam,
I'm playing the album.
I mean like,
wow,
that's crazy.
I put it on speaker,
we sit down and we start laughing about how easy that is to do and how amazing
this music is.
Well,
yeah,
exactly.
I apple,
um,
change the way we think about music,
change the way we think about phones,
um,
and created all of these new technologies.
But here's the,
this happens again,
again in technology as part of the,
let me give you the context.
By the way,
iTunes stores not loading right now just to show you pinwheel.
So it's been willing right now.
I clicked it as you,
as you brought that up.
I said,
let's see.
And I clicked it.
It's fucking not loading.
So what happens with technology
again and again is that you always have to make this trade off.
Do you want to have an experience that's very tightly controlled and therefore
consistent,
right?
You combine a very limited set of hardware,
very limited set of features.
But what you get is that it works every time consistently.
And then you can have this kind of wild west situation as you do with android.
And at first it creates a lot of fragmentation and everything's inconsistent and
it doesn't work very well.
But over time,
here's what happens.
The controlled situation that gave you the advantage at first starts lagging
behind innovation because it can't change fast enough and the wild west starts
getting better and better at quality until eventually it wins.
And we've seen this happen over time.
And then the,
the control situation has to open up the borders again.
Let everybody flood in,
do a lot of fragmentation and experimentation and the cycle starts again.
That's going to happen to,
I mean,
we're going to see much more openness and music.
We're going to see more openness and phones as a result of this.
And then apple will have to actually go out and invent something new.
Um,
instead of just,
you know,
small incremental changes,
oh shit,
it's bothering you,
man,
bothering me and bothering me.
What?
It's 52%,
uh,
android and 41% uh,
is uh,
apple is that you went to Reno was 80.
That's a red 80 somewhere and a apple still has sold more a applications.
It's a,
apple has sold 50 APP,
50 million apps I think or something like that.
An android,
it's up to 48 million apps.
Total soul.
What's bothering you about it?
Man?
81% man on cnet.
Cnet says android dominates 81% of the world's smart phone market.
Yeah,
that's the global versus I think what you quoted as us and it's a very different
market.
Oh,
okay.
Well let's look at it globally.
So Asia,
much bigger android penetration.
Okay.
That's what I read.
I was in Vancouver this weekend and I had to use my android phone completely.
Only using my android phone note.
No iPhone at all.
And it,
I do not understand people that say that the android phone is better in any way.
The camera was horrible.
I tried to take so many photos using that camera and this is the note three that
has like a really nice camera.
That camera is a piece of shit.
All,
all Samsung does is add a bunch of crap to their phones to be the first,
but they do it so halfassed that it just doesn't work like that.
Like you keep on taking this heartbeat sensor and that the thumbprint thing is
one of the worst input.
The thumbprint and the new s five is horrible.
People are saying it's the dumbest thing ever,
that it never works.
It's just a piece of shit.
Well that's exactly the compromise.
You need to have control and tight quality,
but it's slow or you have speed,
but it's,
it's a,
you know,
at first it's flaky.
Yeah.
And I'd be the first director say,
Hey,
you're right at,
you know,
this iPhone is a piece of shit.
I still buy all the newest phones just because I'm looking just like everyone
else to find something better.
But man,
I,
you can't break this thing being quality.
Like it's always working.
You had the best photos you can possibly get.
All the APPS are perfect.
I definitely agree with you on the photos.
There's a big difference between the iPhone photos and the,
uh,
android photos.
I think the sensor,
the,
like the,
the sensor on the iPhone is a lower megapixel but much higher quality.
It's just a better phone.
But I'm like,
what does it mega pixel on the iPhone.
It's like eight,
eight,
eight.
Oh,
forget lenses and things like that make a huge different Carl Zeiss Lens.
It's,
I'm back like it's actually 13 megapixels on the galaxy note three.
Yeah.
But it's not as good.
It's,
it's fine if the light is good.
Are you talking Jamie?
You know,
you don't have a microphone on you motherfucker.
I can't hear you.
What are you doing?
Why don't you make sign language at me?
I can't hear that either.
Um,
the,
uh,
there's,
I mean I think there is a better camera than the iPhone,
but it's not the note three.
I think there is,
I'm sure there is a better camera,
but I'm just saying,
let's find out what's the best.
Let's Google best smart phone camera.
I bet apples in the top two.
There was also reports saying that you know why it's such a big share is not
because of quality.
It's because of price that that android users are more poor and they get more
technology for the money.
So that's why it's become so popular because all the poor markets are buying it.
So it looks like Android's just destroying apple in that,
that regards.
But it's not meaning that it's a better
products.
Smartphone camera overall iPhone five s it's the mass market audience,
especially in in Asia where you can get an android phone for 50 to $100 instead
of three to $400 equivalent for iPhone image stabilization and dual led flash.
She got one of the best phones for taking pictures in low light or any
situation.
Apple has improved its camera app for the five s what's the difference?
Oh it does like photos.
There's slow Mo.
One of the coolest things,
I think you could do this on the android offsites burst mode but,
but being able to adjust and I didn't even know I had it.
If you just hold down the camera,
it just takes a million photos.
So like if you're like with like say like you want a picture of Joe Rogan,
you just sit there,
hold down the camera it was and take like 300 photos and then you can just
choose which one you didn't blink and stuff.
Like
I do miss the camera.
That's the one thing I missed.
But I don't miss that little bitch.
He screen screens a Joe June.
That's all you have to wait.
Yeah,
allegedly.
But that's a 4.71 the 5.51 is not going to be for a long time.
It's September.
So says you,
what are you a Mac insider?
What the fuck?
Do you know
why in this humongous iPads coming out?
Yeah,
that's all good dude.
But this,
I'll take it every day.
I'll take that all day.
It's not important.
The camera's not nearly as important to me as being able to do my email,
go online.
Everything plays like flash.
Anything that has flash on it plays no problem.
I,
that to me is gigantic.
When I look at a youtube video and it's that Goddamn big to me that's huge.
And also the stylists.
I fucking love this thing.
Are you kidding me?
Yeah,
I never use it.
Every time I use the style was like I'm just wasting my time.
Why am I,
why am I doing this?
Well I,
I use it a lot for writing my jokes.
Right.
That's,
that's interesting that you do that too because that's,
it seems so much.
I don't know.
Like I'm just so fast on the keyboard.
Yeah.
I mean it's not the fast thing for me it's a memorization thing.
When you actually write things physically with your hand,
you can remember them better.
And this took I for a long time.
I was still bringing the notebook as well,
but I gave up on the notebook.
I do it all on this thing now.
I thought you meant since this Ipod,
iPad,
air.
I've been taking my iPad almost everywhere and now I don't give a shit about my
phone.
This is just for texting.
You meet pad or my eye,
my iPad,
my iPad.
Air pod.
Yeah.
This thing is so light and like you could just keep it everywhere and like if
you really want to surf the net,
you know even the new one,
the small one.
Yeah,
that is a good move.
But you can't put it in your pocket.
Yeah,
I don't just,
I,
you know,
I honestly just don't trust the,
the,
the apps in the APP store and the Google apps and the back doors and the hacking
hackability of the operating system.
To me,
I think this is the way the iPhone is just a brick and then see it like your
important stuff,
the text messages and your,
your crap like that should have the highest security and not something that
that's so easily been hacked.
So
right here,
this comparison between control,
quality,
but slow innovation versus speed choice,
fragmentation,
but flakiness and weird security problems and cutting edge,
that choice is playing out in many areas of technology,
whether it's and,
and this choice played out on the Internet for at first,
which was the idea that the Internet was a far inferior network to the carefully
controlled,
if you like it,
phone companies were doing the iPhone of networks,
right?
And the Internet was like the scrappy mess.
See android of networks.
But over time it continued to innovate and get better and the other systems got
slower and slower and less innovative.
And so the closest items have that problem.
They lag,
but they offer you much better control and quality and security at first.
So here's the thing that's been happening in finance and in finance,
it's much worse because the closed control systems of the banks have existed for
hundreds of years.
And this scrappy new bitcoin thing,
which is not as fast in many cases,
but fast and other cases has more choice but also puts more responsibility for
security.
It's more flaky,
it's more scrappy,
it's more versatile.
It gives you a hell of a lot more choice and it allows you to innovate really,
really fast,
doesn't give you the quality.
You don't have the,
you know,
the controls and security supposedly,
but then at the same time,
the banking system is failing to deliver to consumers.
It's failing to deliver security because people can get away with massive theft
on it.
And so now what we're seeing is this exact same scenario that you described that
we saw with the Internet versus telecom networks that we saw with iPhone versus
android is now playing out in finance with bitcoin.
That's fascinating.
They say that the best
a camera for power users is that Nokia,
Nokia,
they had 'em on Tom's guide.
Dot.
When I'm reading a,
they've rated a bunch of different ones.
I don't know why Tom Really knows his shit,
but it seems like a highly rated side.
But the 41 megapixel camera apparently just,
it's just unbelievable.
It.
The photos are so big that a,
even when you zoom in like way in like you could take a photo and zoom way in,
it's still crop it and it's still an excellent photo.
Yeah.
That's about the only reason why you'd want that meeting megapixels though.
Right?
Because I'm mega pixels,
people stopped caring about megapixels a while ago for the most part.
Even some of the higher end cameras has kind of stopped.
Even though they could go bigger they,
I mean it's just not as important as it when it was like from one mega pixel
that five megapixels,
unless you're making like billboards,
unless you're making billboards or you really are just going to spend time just
cropping out sections of large photos and even that with a such a small device
that's in your hand.
I would imagine that there's a lot of blur and even if you do crop out little
pieces,
it's still not going to be like something like if you had a tripod and a DSLR or
something.
Yeah.
They're saying that the galaxy s five is a big improvement too from the note
three as far as cameras go.
Yeah.
You get to a point of saturation where it becomes good enough.
You'll remember the time when you bought a computer based on how many gigahertz
it had and how fast it wasn't.
You needed to upgrade every year and then we reached a point probably five or
six years ago when you bought a computer and then it was still perfectly fast
enough for five years later and you didn't need to upgrade it.
Right.
Or when you use the needs a bigger and bigger hard drive every single year and
then you race the tower by and I are like,
well,
I can store everything so I'm done.
I don't need anymore.
Right.
Same thing with megapixels.
You reach a point where at first it makes a really big difference and then it's
such a small difference that it doesn't matter anymore.
You've reached saturation,
you have to find something else to emphasize.
Some new innovation.
Yeah.
At a certain point,
Time's going to be very difficult for one company,
like a company like apple to compete with the overwhelming amount of companies
that are producing android phones.
That's the open ecosystem.
That's the difference between being able to innovate and multiple places versus
trying to control everything and you can really see that too if you pay
attention to the original android phones and what they are today as opposed to
the original iPhone,
which was incredibly innovative,
like the original iPhone is pretty close to what they have today.
I mean it was very similar in size.
Very similar in look.
Obviously the resolution got better,
the camera got better,
it got quicker,
it moves better,
has more,
more features,
but the original android phones were dog shit.
Yes,
they were so bad.
Do you remember Brad?
Did you have one?
Brian at the front went the first droid.
Yeah.
God,
I have one too.
It was so bad.
I had it for one day and I brought it back in.
The Verizon guys were trying to talk me out of it and I go,
nope,
nope.
I'm going to look.
Take it and they're like,
well you don't want to bring it back.
Like just get did get used to it.
I'm telling you,
I really like it.
Get this piece of shit away from me.
Cause I had an iPhone and I would try to switch to a droid to go on Verizon at
the time.
Woo.
Is that what you had Brian?
Yeah.
Here's me doing a review of the first one.
Uh,
the phone has a five megapixel camera.
It's got a flash.
The camera is really good.
It has a watch guy looks though unfortunately.
And you have to
install,
look at all this seems kind of,
you know,
there's some things about it where you're just like,
why don't,
why don't they just copy what works?
You know the iPhone works.
That's the best way to lead applications,
whatever.
Uh,
so there's a couple of things here and there that I know.
What's crazy is that,
you know,
down the line and more that droid started becoming more unpopular.
They did start copying everything that iPhone used and that's why they're in
court right now.
Samsung versus apple in court.
Yeah.
What are the,
what is the lawsuit about,
do you know the specifics?
Oh,
just a lot of different things.
Like,
like uh,
the,
the unlock screen I think like how you unlock the phone and just different like
you know,
operating systems shit that,
that pretty much,
they just kind of just copied
that apple figured out first.
And so the new iPhone is supposed to come out in June,
is that right?
You is supposedly like the new iPhone six and then they're going to have the
giant one.
Supposedly this is just what they do every year where they announced it in June
and then it's like the next month they'll have,
you know,
one come out and then the bigger one,
like I guess in the other reason why they're waiting a little bit longer,
it's because the,
the panels that are going to be using and the new phone or backwards so much
because when starts selling something new,
it's,
you know,
it,
it pretty much just destroys anyone that does that.
You know,
like we make five inch screens.
Well yeah,
apple is going to buy 5 million of these.
So it right.
Their screens are different too than like the,
that was the other thing that I was reading about the difference between the ht
one m eight,
which is like probably the highest rated android phone.
Right.
Um,
have you seen that one?
Yeah,
it's pretty fucking slick.
I even read an actual uh,
apple website was um,
uh,
reviewing the HTC one m eight and they were saying that if apple built uh,
an android phone,
this would be the phone that they built.
It's pretty fucking slick and they actually have a different approach to
camera's entirely.
They have a small mega pixel phone.
That's how slick looking phone apparently the sound on these is incredible.
The sound is supposed to be amazing.
Like literally it sounds like are a little radio like all like a little boombox.
I think that's one of the big deals to that.
Why I haven't been happy with as much as they android is I really think that
Samsung is not actually the best maker of the phones.
I think like even like these HTC seem a little bit
better put together.
Yeah.
Well,
this one is like particularly well designed but this one only has a four
megapixel or if they call ultra pixel phone.
Yeah,
or ultra picture camera rather.
And I don't understand that but it has to camera lenses.
You see what they're doing there while you're clicking back and forth with the
two lenses are there's two different cameras on the back and those two cameras
allow you to blur out the foreground or the background if you so choose to.
It's pretty slick for photos.
I've seen the uh,
the pictures but four megapixels is just,
the images are just not going to be as large.
The real question becomes,
is four megapixels enough,
four phones,
phones are actually taking over cameras.
I,
I'm,
I haven't looked lately but I'm pretty sure that that the camera sales,
especially pointed shooters are completely other than it should or I used to buy
them all the time because you know,
those were great to put in your pocket but now it is,
you don't need it.
Yeah.
I have one that I use just for after shows.
Like why I have people like line up and take pictures with them and then I put
it up on my website cause it cause it saves time.
But um,
the uh,
the actual need for them,
for the average person it's almost nonexistent unless you're like one of those
SLR type people that has a big crazy lens and all that jazz.
I guess that that technology you were talking about like blurring the
foregrounds actually built into the new android operating system that,
that,
that whole thing.
Yeah.
You can do it with software.
The difference with the HTC one is it actually does it with hardware as well and
it's supposed to look slicker.
They have that avail of that ability to do it on the HTC or not the HDC,
the Samsung galaxy s five as well.
You do that in
the background.
I just think that what HTC has decided to do is try to do it with two different
cameras at the same time.
So is this the,
what would you say this is the,
the,
the one to do the buy now.
If you were going to get a new android or,
Gee,
you think the nexus right?
The next,
I love the nexus eyeful.
Yeah,
I like the HTC one two I have to say I think both of them are great,
great hardware solutions.
Then you have to really be careful about what software is loaded on them because
depending on which car you get it from,
they're going to have different quality of software.
Where this is the latest kit Kat or an earlier version I get,
my phone's on locked,
I wiped them and I replaced the software with my own choices immediately.
Right.
It does.
How hard is that?
How much time does that take?
It's not a matter of,
I mean it takes me two or three days to get everything done,
but I mean,
you know,
not,
not full time time.
That's a lot of time.
Nobody does this stuff.
Listen,
I'm a,
I'm a technology contrary and I,
android versus iPhone.
I do android windows versus Linux.
I do Linux even when it's at first dog shits,
user experience.
I do it anyway for the freedom and the versatility.
Mac Laptop and I'm an early adopter on a bitcoin and so yeah,
I have a Mac laptop and I run the run apple on or I read something crazy.
I run apple on it tonight.
Also run Linux machines on it too as virtual machines.
Um,
so I have a combination of operating systems here.
But you run Linux on an apple laptop,
you could do that.
Yeah,
it was not official.
I know that you could do that.
They still have that option to run windows on Mac laptops.
We've got windows seven here,
two windows
man.
Have you used lately?
It's so do they,
when are they just going to give up and start over?
Not going to they uh,
they still have a giant chunk of the market.
Yeah,
I love what they're doing now is that they're actually making money off a still
supporting windows 98 to banks.
Like they were like,
no,
we give up on windows 98 or XP and we give up on windows XP,
but will you know if you want to pay us.
Did you remember when they had windows stores at the mall that didn't sell
anything?
Yeah,
they had a windows store and I went in.
I'm like,
do you guys sell computers?
They go,
no.
I go,
what the fuck are you doing?
You guys are windows and you don't sell computers.
While we're windows were not computer sellers.
We're,
we're an operating system.
They sold windows.
You could buy windows there.
Yeah.
The coups talk.
Who's running this?
Let me talk to that guy.
He,
dude,
this is fucking stupid.
You have all this cool shit.
Like you should like have a variety of different manufacturers have really cool
computers.
Yeah.
Maybe I'm wrong.
They haven't been out of the windows store is now sell everything.
Laptops.
They have all that stuff.
The surface and it's still not of itself.
Yeah.
You know,
I'm more interested in these,
these into android notebooks.
I saw one the other day.
I think that's the way to go.
If you just want it a little teeny notebook to put in your,
you know,
the check email and stuff like that.
Maybe they did sell computers and I'm wrong.
Okay.
I think there were some early windows stores that didn't and it was just more
like kiosks or no,
not,
yeah,
when I went to one of them that's what are,
maybe I'm wrong,
I'm trying to remember cause it was quite a while ago,
but I remember going in and my kids were playing with like one of the things
that they,
like I said says this article on cio.com for things you'll love about HTCs once
and for you won't.
What you won't love about the HTC one inmate duo camera is disappointing single
most unfortunately.
Thing about HD one is to camera.
Okay.
The device rear facing four megapixel duo camera with ultra pixel technology
stop moving two different lenses allows user to d checked and calculate the
relative distance of subjects in the image.
Sounds cool.
Right?
Well except for the measly four megapixels,
it doesn't take long to at all to realize that while the camera works fairly
well in dimly lit environments.
Oh.
So that was the idea.
They kept with the low mega pixel to or another function better in low
environments,
but then that that quality turned the Tay is to be left to be desired.
So the,
the,
the what you're going to use it most of the time,
probably during the day.
It sucks.
Okay.
So there's only two options that are really good if you want to go with,
uh,
with,
with phones,
it's a,
that Lumina and the,
uh,
the apple,
those are the two big ones.
Oh.
And then apparently there's Sony Xperia too for cameras.
Yeah.
The Sony Xperia apparently has a pretty dope camera too.
So I think the reason they're putting two cameras on the back of the phone,
which would be interesting is where you get to the ability to shoot 3-d
directly.
Because if you think about it,
this phone is now wide enough that you can separate the cameras if five about as
much as your eyes are separated at the focal distance and then you can shoot,
um,
direct three d off two cameras.
Well,
do you remember when they had that?
For awhile they had three d photography on some of those crazy phones.
You remember?
Was it good enough?
There were really weird and it only worked on your phone.
It wouldn't work on the computer.
Look at there
the first,
the first iteration is always clooci and heal,
but I like to have the choice.
Yeah.
Cloogy let's close.
You mean it's,
it's rough.
It's rough around the edges.
Would have ever used an English word to start using g chord.
He'd be herbal.
How dare you double it?
Urban Dictionary.
Is it?
Oh,
it's an urban one.
I dunno.
It's a geek.
It's a geek term,
but I mean it's the first iteration of the technology has always flaky,
but if it's a powerful and disruptive enough,
then there'll be an incentive to make it better.
When when I use the first iterations of web browsers,
there were terrible.
The first versions of android there were terrible,
and guess what?
The first versions of bitcoin wallets are terrible,
but I have choice and I love that.
I'd love,
I'd rather be on the cutting edge and be dealing with something that's rough
around the edges and get to experience the technology as it matures.
Eventually it will get to the point where it's as easy to use as an IPAD,
which is how my mom got on the Internet and Bitcoin,
we'll get to that point to,
uh,
to me choices,
more importance than,
than Polish.
But for other people they go with the opposite choice and that's perfectly
understandable.
That's interesting man.
Yeah,
I agree with you in a lot of ways,
but I think that there's a similarity to a windows and apple,
you know,
the,
as far as like apple phones and you know,
the whole idea of the way apple lock things down and controls it and windows
where they don't and they allow you to get into the registry,
the allow you to do a lot of things with the computers and a lot of power users
like break it.
Yeah.
The average person might,
it might fuck it up and up.
So do you think that that could possibly have like a rational,
uh,
effect on Apple's decision to not have bitcoin wallets outside of the commerce?
Oh,
absolutely.
Yeah.
So as I said,
you know,
the,
the straightforward one is that it introduces risk and an environment that is
deliberately conservative about quality,
security and control over the environment.
So they're going to be slow to adopt things that are disruptive
and it's also self serving because it threatens their payment network and it
might be self serving because it also threatens their ability to introduce their
own form of digital currency with digital wallets,
which there are a lot of rumors that they're in,
in working on that.
Um,
I,
I don't,
yeah,
I mean you can take all of those together and it makes sense,
but it's not a longterm decision because if there's enough momentum behind
digital currencies,
eventually they're going to add them slower than everybody else,
but they will get it.
Have you thought about the future and looked at like the trends,
the technological trends,
and tried to extrapolate,
like what would be the method for exchanging controlling bitcoin in the very
near future?
Is there like a better version of what these apps can provide on phones that you
believe could be implemented sometime in the near future?
Oh,
absolutely.
I mean,
at the moment,
um,
you,
you don't want to have a lot of the raw elements of the system expose to users
who don't want to learn anything about these.
So right now there's a pretty steep learning curve if you want to understand
digital crypto currencies,
uh,
just the name alone,
like crypto currencies sounds so awfully geeky and weird,
but if you want to understand digital money,
let's start by renaming that,
right?
So it's a digital money.
If you want to understand digital money,
um,
you get introduced these terms,
public key,
private key encryption,
address wallet,
a Bitcoin address,
uh,
transaction.
All of these are confusing terms because they don't actually mean what they,
what they,
what you think they mean.
So a bitcoin wallet is not actually a wallet because it doesn't contain coins.
It only contains the keys that allow you to unlock the coins.
The coins are actually on the network and you get into all of these things where
you've picked a name that name evokes a thought,
but that thought doesn't quite match what's really happening.
So it ends up confusing rather than enlightened.
Right?
So a good name is one that tells you how this is going to work because it evokes
the correct paradigm,
the correct user interface
design.
And so we don't have that in bit coin yet.
The words are wrong,
the terminology is wrong.
The user interface and user experience is still very,
very geeky.
And you know,
that happened on the Internet.
I remember watching in 1994 there's this classic segment on Good Morning America
when the like,
so,
so the thing with the at sign is that the Internet,
no,
Kelly.
That's,
that's email and um,
and the dots,
that's,
that's the internet.
And so why are there all the slashes and what does an IP address?
And I don't really understand any of this.
Right.
It,
and you get to two things.
One,
the technology gets smoother and more polished,
and the words get at the same time,
the culture changes and the culture gradually adopts the terminology so that now
people are more comfortable with a weird words and the words have gotten less
weird and somewhere in the middle of the meat and you get mainstream adoption.
Uh,
are people working on trying to get any sort of a bit coin wallet reintroduced
into the Apple,
the APP store because there was one for a while,
right?
Was there more than one or was one,
it was more than one.
And now there's more to,
there's new ones have been reintroduced already to the apple store.
Yes,
absolutely.
They use a few little,
um,
how do I call this loopholes?
Are you,
I'm outing them or should we not say their name?
I won't say their names at the moment,
but there are ways to do this.
Then what's the point?
You're the fucking bitcoin.
Jesus.
If you don't say their names,
they don't get promoted and they fucking die on the vine.
You'll get pulled immediately.
Well they get pulled immediately.
If you say their name Amy later for Nintendo's like a pop up almost every day on
the story.
It's like some backdoor into something like food cooking programs.
People want,
if people want to find bitcoin wallets for I os they can search for those terms
and find them.
And essentially the other way to do it is by building a pure html five wallet,
the runs entirely in the browser.
And then it's not an app you install,
it's a page you visit,
but it's fully functional.
It looks like an application that they have those we're building those.
Every company in the space is building one of those right now to avoid the whole
APP system,
uh,
to get around the APP system and to enable users to use it through the browser.
And you still have to use Apple's browser though.
Correct?
You can't use chrome yet.
Can you can use chrome for apple?
Yeah.
I have a chrome application.
They have Microsoft word now on Ios.
Right.
So any html five browser.
And that's the nice thing about html five.
It's the new version of the web
protocol and it will run on any browser on any device and it will give you a
full app like experience.
It doesn't feel like a webpage.
It feels like an application.
So That's interesting.
Yeah,
that's really interesting.
So that we'll cut it all out.
If you can get online then you can get to this web page,
then you can trade bitcoin period.
So exactly.
And this is what's exciting about the bitcoin space for me,
which is that uh,
we talk about this idea that we're going to convert dollars to bitcoin.
Like if only say Amazon adopts Bitcoin,
then all of the stuff they're selling through bitcoin will now be sold through a
will that be solved through bitcoin instead of dollars.
And it's like chewing out little parts of the,
of the traditional economy and just converting it into a different currency.
And that is boring.
It is.
So not the point.
That's a bit like thinking that,
you know,
the Internet succeeds when all phone calls happen on the Internet and we've
taken over the entire facts market and now facts is dominated by Internet,
fax.
And the whole point is that it made facts irrelevant.
It didn't replace it,
it made it irrelevant and it didn't replace phone calls.
It gave people better communication tools and different communication tools.
I'm more interested in what we can do with bitcoin that can be done today rather
than replacing the things we already do with dollars or visa and making a bet of
visa,
better pay pal,
a better online shopping experience.
That stuff is board.
So here's what's happening within the bitcoin economy,
there's now hundreds of startups and they're hiring people.
We're,
we have a jobs fair in Sunnyvale on May 3rd,
uh,
where we're going to have hundreds of people and dozens of companies with job
open openings,
hiring developers and designers and marketing professionals and all kinds of
things like that.
Now,
uh,
for those who are probably new to this market,
a jobs fair is this thing that happened before 2008 where companies actually had
jobs and would come to you in order to find you.
Yes.
And we're doing this in bitcoin because of this incredible spirit of innovation
that's been unleashed.
So if you're an entrepreneur and you look at these rough edges and you look at
these difficulties in the system,
and you'd look at the fact that it's not ready for mainstream adoption,
what you see as opportunity,
massive opportunity.
Because remember at first on the Internet,
you couldn't find anything.
So someone said,
well,
how about we build a search engine?
And now that's a multi hundred billion dollar company,
right?
And search became,
uh,
an entire industry out of a single problem.
And the problem was you couldn't find anything.
Now you can find everything.
And so at first people said,
well,
the Internet is never going to succeed because you can't find anything on the
Internet.
And smart entrepreneurs took that problem and said,
no,
if I solve this problem,
not only do I make the internet work,
but I also creates an entirely new industry.
So right now,
bitcoin is difficult to use.
But if you solve that problem,
if you take for example the fact that a bitcoin addresses like a 37 character
thing and it's unreadable and you hide that,
just like we no longer use IP addresses on the Internet,
we use nice and easy to use names.
We used to use,
you know,
one nine two.one six eight.zero.one and you had to,
I had the list in my wallet of Ip addresses.
If I want it to go to the Stanford website,
I had to pull out my wallet and look up their Ip address.
That's how I used to work and there was no way that was going to go mainstream.
So each one of these problems,
he's one of these rough edges is an opportunity to create a whole new industry
that does things in a different way that reinvents financial services in the
makes them new and innovative and decentralized and enables things that have
never been done before.
This is not about making a better shopping experience.
It's about doing things we couldn't do before.
And eventually people are going to build wallets that are very easy to use and
wallets that are going to be very beautifully designed.
And we're beginning to see that now as all of these startups are rushing in to
fill in the gaps,
to polish all the rough edges and to deliver real quality consumer products that
people can take this incredible underlying power of bitcoin and turn it into an
everyday experience that a person who doesn't want to know about any of the
geeky stuff about encryption,
about keys,
about all of that simply says,
I want to send Joe some money and the wallet is Joe Money Send and all of the
rest is hidden in the background and we're getting there
and we are getting there and it's,
it sort of mirrors what's already been done with the Internet so that people
could sort of see the path.
It's not like it's some completely new thing that's never been done before.
No one's ever taken something that was unbelievably complex,
simplified it and made it mainstream online.
Yeah,
they have.
And they,
you could see it.
So with bitcoin it's like the path has already lit.
He just have to get people that are brave enough to step forward.
And that's obviously happening
except for one fundamental difference.
We don't have to lay hundreds of thousands of miles of new copper and fiber
line,
don't caption build the physical infrastructure because it's already there.
The Internet took,
you know,
a decade and a half to spread in terms of adoption and one of the big issues was
getting high speed Internet to enough people and then getting fully on all the
time intranet.
You remember the days of dialogue
and but modems going be
right and to Carl London now,
it was impossible to get my mom to do email if she had to first turn on the
computer and log on Doubleclick,
start the dialogue,
do all of this with her phone.
That made her phone busy so she couldn't actually use it and it would drop off
sometimes too.
And then connect and sync the EMA that are now
she,
she swipes her iPad and the email is there and she doesn't know how it works.
All of this is always on.
It's Wifi,
it's simple,
boom,
done.
That's the progression we're going to see.
That's fascinating.
Um,
what are right now as of today,
what,
what are the changes in bitcoin since the last time you were on?
Um,
there are some really interesting things happening.
I think,
so,
let's see.
It's been a while.
You know,
in,
in real life it's been two and a half months,
which in bitcoin terms is like two and a half years.
So much has happened is just ridiculous.
One of the interesting things we've seen is serious efforts and results in
building multisignature capabilities.
I don't think we even talked about that last time or maybe we mentioned it
briefly.
What is multisignature capabilities?
So this is a feature that was added to the core protocol,
the bitcoin protocol back in November of 2013 officially and would work.
So when you send bitcoin to someone,
what you're doing is almost like signing a digital check.
And you're saying from Joe Rogan's wallets and you sign at the bottom to say,
yes,
I'm releasing this money to red band.
Great.
So you've sent it and the bitcoin network will look at that signature and say,
that's Joe Rogan signature.
Great.
So therefore now the money belongs to read.
Ben,
you've done the transaction.
So what your wallet is doing,
what's your phone is doing when it's sending bitcoins to someone?
Is it signing a transaction with your key to,
to basically say,
I authorize this.
Um,
it takes one signature to release the money from your law firm.
Your Wallet Multisig allows you to build wallets that require multiple
signatures.
So let's say you were running a company and you want it to make sure that every
single time you made a bitcoin transaction,
it had to be signed by the CEO and the chief financial officer,
right?
So now you could say,
well,
a requires two out of two signatures.
The account has two signatures associated with it.
Both must sign in order to do that.
Or You could create a joint account between two spouses and you could say a
requires one of two signatures.
Here is the signature of one spouse has the signature of the other spouse.
If either of them signs,
you can do it right.
Um,
you could create a trust account where you have,
um,
either the signature of one spouse and a trustee or the other spouse and a
trustee to sign off for the account of a child.
For example,
you could create an escrow account where you say,
I'm going to sell you Joe something and you send me the bitcoin and I don't
deliver.
What happens then that's a problem,
right?
You can't get a refund.
Now instead of that,
you send the Bitcoin to an account that requires to have three signatures,
your signature,
my signature,
and an escrow party,
a third party that works as an arbitrator between us.
So if I send you the stuff that you wanted and you are happy with it,
we both sign,
I get the money,
right?
So you've paid me.
It's like an escrow like you do with paypal and Ebay.
Right now,
if we have a dispute,
you call the arbitrator and you say,
I'm not happy I didn't get this product and you and the arbitrator sign and get
the refund,
send the money back to you.
But if I'm not satisfied,
because I really did send you the product and you just don't want to pay for it,
I persuade the arbitrator that you're cheating.
I sign it with the arbitrator.
Two out of three signatures,
get the money to myself.
So you can create these complex environments where you can do escrow,
you can do trust accounts,
you can have arbitration,
third party arbitration for refunds so that you can solve problems and you can
create more complex forms of transactions that give you better security and
better trust.
That seems,
um,
like you would really have to trust the arbitrator and the,
they would have to somehow or another not being cahoots with one party.
Yeah.
So when you use the visa network,
you abide by visas,
arbitration rules,
right?
So if you do a charge back and they're going to contact the merchant and say,
well,
show us a signature from this transaction and feess arbitration rules apply
whether you'd like it or not.
When you use Ebay,
paypal arbitration rules apply whether you like it or not,
the means of payment determines the rules of arbitration.
So that seems like a good opportunity for something like Bank of America to get
involved with.
Yes.
Paypal could be one of the arbitrators if you'd like.
Oh thank you.
If you like the,
uh,
arbitration rules of that group,
you could use them.
Here's the,
here's the interesting things though.
What it does is it allows you to say,
I'm going to have a market of arbitration providers all with different rules and
different levels of trust.
And some of them will have very good reviews because people had group could
experience with them and some of them are specialized in real estate and some of
them are specialized in um,
auction markets.
And some of them specialize in antiques and some of them are specialized in art
or appraisal.
And so I'm doing a transaction with you and I want to buy an antique.
I'm going to list 200 antique arbitrators.
I'm going to pick the one with the highest level of refuse.
He's an experts in appraising antiques.
He's going to do a good job for us.
We agree.
That's the one we want to use.
Now we've got,
it's opens up all of these possibilities and it creates a whole new market for
these services.
So you've taken trust.
The was centralized in someone like paypal.
You didn't have a choice but to use their arbitration and you decentralize it.
Tonight you have a market where the buyer and the seller can decide what rules
apply.
So do you believe that this is very similar to what we were talking about before
with banks?
That one person just has to do it,
start profiting on it,
and the rush will be
for all the other sort of joining on the bandwagon?
There's already an arbitration market where lawyers and real estate agents and
others are providing arbitration services for a small transaction fee like 0.1%
of the transaction in order to provide escrow capabilities.
And you can do that when you buy something with Bitcoin,
you can now use escrow and this is all within the last time you were here.
Um,
the technology was nascent and the services were still being built and now
they're,
they're being built faster.
So that two months really is like two years.
Yeah.
Let me give you another example,
which is really cool.
A lot of people are worried about their bitcoin being stolen from their wallets
because of a hack.
So one of the ways you can use multisig,
which is very interesting,
is to have a two have three account.
And what I mean by two of three,
it means it has three signatures registered and you require at least two of
those three signatures in order to authorize the transaction.
You keep one,
you keep another one as a backup,
put it printed on paper,
put it in a safe,
that's your recovery in case something goes wrong.
And then you give the third signature to a service that checks every transaction
for risk.
And what they do is when you make a payment,
they,
they look at the merchant that you paid,
they look at their history,
they look at what kind of amount it is.
Is this usual,
is it like $10 and you normally spend that or did you just suddenly tried to
transfer half a million dollars out of your accounts and wipe it clean to a
random address they've never seen before.
And so based on that,
they're going to risk score it and then they're going to call you,
they're going to send you a text message and say,
we seeing a transaction here,
you've requested for two and a half thousand dollars to merchant we've never
seen before that you normally don't do.
Are you sure you know,
respond one for authorizing this transaction,
respond to to cancel it.
And if it's a really big one,
maybe they're going to call you on the phone and you're going to speak to Jim
and Jim is going to say,
um,
can you please give me the last four of your social,
I want to check this,
whatever you can,
you can reintroduce some of the fraud prevention systems that banks do.
But the really cool thing is now that's a market instead of having to do it with
your payment provider,
you can pick who gives you a risk service.
Yeah,
it's fascinating,
but it's sort of along the same lines of the difference between apple locking
everything down.
You know,
it's secure.
You're not going to get a virus from an APP and the wild world of like,
like say perfect example would be like a bit torrent.
Yes.
Fucking download a program from bit torrent.
Good lucks on.
Better Cross your fingers because you never know.
What the hell are you going to get?
Right?
So here's the thing.
I mean,
by the way,
these pickles are God damn delicious.
If you want to pick over Grillo's pickles sent us some,
uh,
some pickles are amazing.
Have you had the sweet ones?
Yes.
If my favorite one one.
Can you now come to normal Joe,
go over and buy Grillo's pickles or is there a website?
Is it just like local
shit?
Only.
Only people.
Yeah.
No,
you can get them delivered.
Grillo's pickles.com delivers.
Now they're the nicest guys that were too.
They came to our show in Boston and they were,
if he gave out free pickles to the whole crowd,
dude,
probably like a million dollars for the pickles and handed it out to 2000
people.
It's all fresh jail.
They take bitcoin,
they should those pickles good on the ball badge.
You shouldn't really start bitcoin now.
Right?
Like,
like if I wanted to buy Bitcoin,
I wouldn't want to start now.
I would wait when await because I'm not going to spend what,
$500 for a single bitcoin.
Can you buy pieces of Bitcoin?
You can buy first small amounts we can.
Where do you do that?
So most of the,
uh,
most of the exchanges or place where you can buy Bitcoin,
you can probably buy like,
I think the minimum is $20 for something like that worth.
Okay.
So you can buy a,
a 20th of a bitcoin.
Theoretically,
you could go and buy a hundred millions of a bitcoin if somebody who was willing
to sell it to you.
But the,
usually the,
it's not worth doing for them at that amount.
Um,
so you can divide it as much as he wants.
It's,
you do not need to spend an enormous amount.
And then again,
the thing is what are you gonna use it for?
If you,
if you're going to try and use bitcoin to invest in Bitcoin,
be very,
very careful.
Do not take your retirement funds and all of your savings and dump them into
this wild ride that is not smart.
Right?
And I need to say that again and again.
People don't do that.
I mean,
I've done some of that and it's not prudent,
but my career is tied to this.
I'm in the industry,
this is not for the mainstream investor.
And it's not really an investment,
but I'm sorry,
who's cool.
Maybe put a couple of percentage points of a nicely diversified portfolio like
that.
I'll throw,
you know,
$1,000 maybe $2,000 if I lose it,
I lose it.
If I don't,
in the meantime I can play with it.
I can buy a bit of bit coin,
learn about the technology,
feel like I'm part of an early adopter thing.
That's cool.
Don't go putting all your money in bitcoin.
That's not smart.
What happened?
That one dude who had like $9 million in bitcoin in a hard drive and he couldn't
find it,
so he was going to the dump with a fine tooth comb trying to figure out where
that hard drive was.
Do you remember that story?
Yeah.
Well fortunately he didn't buy that bitcoin.
He was just one of the people who were involved in mining several years back and
then he forgot about it and then he realized this whole hard drive heats thrown
away.
Ashley had a wallet which had seven and a half thousand bitcoin on it or
something like that.
It's hilarious by the way.
But it's no loss.
You're going to have treasure hunters as a new occupation.
It's no loss because he didn't actually have it.
You know,
he didn't.
He didn't.
Um,
but if he had it,
he would have it.
It could be a gain loss.
Yes.
It's a fucking law.
Yeah.
It's not going to keep the dude from committing suicide.
Well,
um,
Eh,
I think it's going to create a whole new treasure hunting business.
People are going to start,
um,
and already we've seen this.
People buy old computers on Ebay.
Go through the hard drives and find wallets on them or porn or financial
information.
Identity theft.
Yeah.
You got to be,
people need to know that too.
If you get rid of a hard drive,
you've got to wipe that bitch clean a strike.
You have to do more than that.
Like you,
you gave me a bunch of your hard drives out,
wipe them clean by.
Still didn't throw them away because I know that there's programs out there that
could just do that.
So now I'm thinking like,
what do you do?
You just dip them in acid or we should shoot him.
Take him to the place sheet.
That'd be fine.
Let's do it.
Alright,
well we're having this conversation at the very moment.
We're having this conversation,
like my watch keeps buzzing every now and then.
What do you got on your watch?
It's a pebble.
It's a smartwatch.
Oh,
how dare you.
You're one of those guys.
Well,
I'm getting Bitcoin,
not notifications of people tipping me over Twitter as we're speaking.
Very,
very cool.
I'm sitting here and as I say things,
if,
if I say something that people like my watch buzzes a bit because people start
sending me tips.
So that's pretty cool.
That's pretty cool.
And now it's buzzing lots.
Once I said deal from you,
can they be like,
fuck you?
Can you get like a negative shock?
Could you say something stupid?
Are you willing to take a chance?
I think that's a,
again,
that's what I said.
If you're an entrepreneur,
there was an opportunity.
Yeah.
Pay someone to wear a shock collar that's written by Bitcoin.
So I got my blocked,
I just read,
downloaded my blockchain app and uh,
and,
and you know,
just checking to see I,
what number am I,
should I give out?
People were like,
Brian,
what's your number?
Address this address right here,
right.
This is,
there's no dangers of giving her,
people were telling me,
oh,
it's like giving out your email address.
Okay.
Better actually because it doesn't reveal any information about where you are or
who you are or any of that.
Okay.
Well it allows people to do is send you money.
Sweet.
And that's nice because you can,
you can put that down on the tee shirt.
You can put it on a QR code.
In fact,
there was this guy who went to a football game with a giant Qr code date printed
and during the ESPN coverage when they were on the Jumbo Tron,
they held it up and it said,
pay for my college or something like that.
They made like two and a half grand or in,
in a matter of minutes because people would see it on TV,
take a snapshot and send them a little bit coin.
Wow.
Why not?
There's a congressman who went to a recent meeting wearing a sandwich board with
a Qr Code on the front where you could donate bid bitcoin to.
Wow.
It's perfectly safe.
You could publish that.
You can put it on posters around the city if he wants to.
My tweet it right now.
That's fantastic.
That's when to Joe.
So many people ask me for your bitcoin address so they could send you bitcoin.
Tell me what it is if you still have the application.
Absolutely.
Yeah.
We'll give it out.
We'll see what happens.
If somebody sent me one too and I'm like,
how the fuck did you begin?
I know it's really funny.
The the,
the,
the watch is buzzing all the time.
Watch.
I'm not a,
I'm not a big fan of that Dick Tracy Watch.
That shit's ridiculous.
I only use it.
You don't want to use it for most of the time for notifications on trip it when
I'm traveling it tells you like,
and it goes gate change and I don't miss my flight.
I mean that,
that's useful.
Yeah.
I heard the pebbles the best one out right now.
Still quite new them songs.
I'm enjoying it a lot.
Yeah.
What's the difference between the Samsungs and the pebble and I don't know.
I got this as a gift a and just the only one I've ever used and I'm just still
playing with it.
So here's something weird that happened to me after the first Joe Rogan my
thing.
Yet.
You still got it.
There are just like somebody sent me one too.
Yeah,
right after I got some big in front of a camera with that.
How will that work?
People can see the Qr Code on,
on your phone.
You can hold it up to the camera that's pointing at me over there behind you
and,
and that will and uh,
is that going to work there you go right there.
Once the,
yeah,
once the brightness that's good.
Stabilizes.
Yeah,
but you can publish that address and that's a,
that's Joe Rogan's bitcoin address right there.
And hopefully you can say hello to Joe with money
and you can publish it later and you can just copy that,
put it in an email or give me any real money.
I'll donate it to charity by the way.
Yeah,
just to let you know that's,
that's always a good thing to do and by the way,
charity is,
has become one of the dominant forms of payments in bitcoin.
A lot of people who are doing a lot with charity and it's because you can send
money very quickly.
You can see how the money is being spent.
There's this fantastic charity that I'd like to mention,
which is based in Pensacola,
Florida,
where they've made it pretty much illegal to be homeless,
the first band sleeping outdoors than they banned blankets and they tried to
solve the homeless problem by bossing them into other cities around and kick
them out of the area.
I support that.
How do we do that?
Sweet Brian,
you've missed the point.
The point is that's evil.
Those poor people are poor.
Actually.
Most of them are veterans coming back from the war and having no jobs in having
PTSD and no treatments and I don't know if most of them,
but there are quite a few 40% 40% of the homeless population in this country is
made up of veterans.
That's a shame.
So,
uh,
Jason King from Sean's outpost children's health post.com started collecting
money for with bitcoin and use that money last year in the first year of the
charity to feed 60,000 meals to the homeless people of Pensacola,
Florida.
And managed to create fundraising events from all around the world and to
convert that money very effectively into food for people who desperately needed.
And that's just one example,
is a lot of charity a bit give the bit gift foundation,
which coordinates charitable giving a hundred bitcoins,
which is a charity that will literally give a 100 bitcoins to any charity that
wants to take bitcoin.
They already have,
they've raised the money and now they're trying to find charities to give the
money away to.
How can I,
I mean that was just an image.
That thing was just an image.
The the the Bitcoin,
the Barcode.
Yeah,
whatever it is.
How do you,
how would I put that online
so I can,
I can,
I've received one screenshot.
I've received one w o 0.01
it's already happening approximately $4 and 92 cents for 20 years.
Oh Shit.
My phone's blowing up.
This has got five bitcoins or five donations just from that stupid image.
That's incredible.
What if I put that image online?
How do you make a screenshot with an android phone?
I can,
I can send you a Qr Code that corresponds to your address is fairly easy for me
to generate it.
You can share that Qr code through the application or you can just post the
address above it.
The QR code is just the address.
It's the same number that starts with a one.
That long series of digits is just in the form of a barcode.
To make it easier,
I need to find out how you screenshot with the galaxy.
Note three.
I use mine I,
there's different ways you can do it.
Mine,
I just swipe my hand from left or right eye over the screen and I do the
screenshot,
but I,
I think I chose to do that through the sections.
Hmm.
There's gotta be a way,
right?
Yeah.
But there's got to be like an easier way.
Was like a button you press or something like that.
Open settings,
motions and gestures.
Oh,
that's the only way to do it.
Huh?
That's s five.
It doesn't always work.
Yeah.
But before we're done with the show,
uh,
I'll get that barcode ready for you.
You could post it on this show and see what happens.
Okay.
You press the power button and the home button at the same time.
Power.
But so how did he get those?
How did he get that cool bar on his,
the Barcode?
Yeah.
You just touched the Barcode on the home screen of your application.
Okay.
All right.
I'm going to it.
We'll make it bigger.
I'm going to send this image,
I'm going to put it on Instagram and then we'll see what's up.
Let's see if this does something.
If you click on the receive button,
right Ben?
Yeah.
And then I think it's one of the tabs at the bottom.
And then
when you do,
you've got the,
yeah.
The problem is they won't let us make new iPhone application as is lagging
behind.
I mean,
there you go.
Stay still.
Let me download it though,
because I got a new iPhone the other day and they still let me download the old
program off the iTunes store.
Oh,
maybe because you already had it on your iTunes.
If you already own something,
you are still allowed to,
right.
Redownload it for somehow.
Hmm.
Really?
Yeah.
So even if it's gone.
That's interesting.
Yeah.
It's kind of like,
so people that spent money on something,
they are,
they still own that product so they can't really take it away.
Okay.
I just instagrammed it,
which means it also went to my Twitter and my Facebook.
So almost 2 million people have access to that image right now.
Let's see if my phone exploded.
I've,
I've had that happen with an explosive,
let me tell you a great story of a fundraising using bitcoin.
Did you hear about this story with music week where they came out and said,
we found the
creator of Bitcoin?
Yeah.
The Comodo
the thing I wanted to talk to you about most today.
Great.
I have a great story for you,
exactly about what happens and we've got a video online to share as well.
Okay.
So I was a conference the morning I found out about this and I looked into it
and a lot of people in the bitcoin space are interested in who Satoshi Nakamoto
is.
There have been a lot of research.
I think we should leave the person alone and it's probably not going to be good
to find out who it is because all it's gonna do is smear that person.
They're going to try and smear him.
So I would rather not know because it doesn't matter.
It's the math is what matters,
not who it is,
but people are all variously curious.
Um,
when I found out about this,
uh,
person in the Los Angeles area that was fingered by Newsweek as a Satoshi
Nakamoto,
then,
uh,
and by the way,
I don't want to create more publicity for this poor man because he is not
Satoshi and it's been become abundantly clear.
Uh,
we've got a lot of writing by the original creator of Bitcoin and it doesn't
match any of the style of it.
Beginning of tone of scion,
constant vibrate right now,
let's US listen.
It's just constantly vibrating.
Make it happen.
Bitcoin community.
I'm counting on you.
That's all big coin come in and right now.
Yeah.
Dollar dollar bills y'all.
That's awesome.
Uh,
Justin wren fight for the forgotten you're getting all this money,
dude.
Justin wren up our power that's in the Congo.
Oh,
I'll send it.
That's great.
Exactly.
Yeah.
He,
um,
he's a great guy who's living in the Congo right now and he builds wells for
these pygmies.
It gets the medicine.
This poor guy has gotten,
he's gotten horrible diseases.
Why?
He's been down there.
He had dang gay fever.
You almost fucking died.
And uh,
he is dedicating his,
his entire life to do this.
So I will,
uh,
I will donate all of this to my friend Justin,
and it's going to keep coming in.
So,
Holy Shit,
dude,
that's nuts.
It okay.
So the,
this is pure madness.
When I feel my phone,
can I sit on it?
Put it up your ass.
I have a hunger yet.
So coming in,
this is ridiculous as a big community out there and they're very generous.
Yeah.
No they most certainly are.
I'm not kidding ladies and gentlemen.
I got about a hundred donations in the past minute.
Wow.
And you did phone to keep up.
You didn't need to make any arrangements with these people.
They didn't eat and there was no banks and fall off.
There was nothing.
It was just direct from them to you.
Boom.
Charity happening in real time.
Yeah.
This is crazy.
Okay,
that's cool.
Yeah.
This is madness man.
Some people are donating real money too.
You can't steal my bitcoin dude.
Are you a hacker?
I've,
I've received,
I've received that.
Um,
in some cases exceeded $3,000 in a single donation for chart for a charitable
cause.
That's incredible.
Wow.
Okay.
They're people are sending me like 20 bucks.
It's crazy.
Yeah.
Like there's a lot of them man.
And not like a few,
like a lot of them that are like 20 bucks.
Cause it tells you what it is approximately by today's standard.
When it,
when it pops up.
This is nuts,
man.
I met her,
shut my fucking phone off.
I'm going to run out of battery.
Just close the program
on a Samsung.
You have to hold it down.
I turned it to like,
how dare you.
Don't fucking shut up dude.
You don't know shit.
Fuck.
And you're an apple fan boy.
You knew that about that blow your fucking apple family.
Do you mind by just going there?
Ah,
fuck you.
Well I can.
No,
you task manager,
you just press close all.
You don't even have that option on the iPhone.
Suck upon it.
You don't even have a task manager bitch.
So you can't just shut them all off.
What's that noise?
Yeah.
Somebody hacked your shit.
They started playing game music.
What's that?
BITCOIN's face.
The cover of Newsweek.
So this is a story that Newsweek broke about.
That guy.
Uh,
I'll say Angeles.
Um,
and here's the funny story.
So his name is Satoshi Nakamoto.
Actually,
it's a Dorian Percival Satoshi Nakamoto.
He doesn't go by Satoshi goes by Dorian and he's nuts.
He's not the creator of Bitcoin.
There's no doubt in anyone's mind at this point and was awake,
fucked up big time and they got it wrong and worse.
They doxed him,
as we say on the Internet,
they produce pictures of his home address and his car registration plate.
And so he got swamped and not just by journalists,
he got swamped by crazies,
by a really crazy dangerous people who suddenly thought he was a rich person and
wanted a piece of the action.
Um,
it was a really horrible thing to do.
Very responsible journalism.
And I'm a very big supporter of free speech and I thank him as well.
But if Newsweek does responsible about that kind of thing,
right?
If News Week does crappy journalism,
they have every right to do that.
And we have every right to call it crappy journalism's not crappy journals.
I'm that guy deserves a sue.
The fucking shit out of them will work.
Not Work.
Not In this country,
not in California.
You why not?
First Amendment is very powerful,
but there's you out at a guy.
He gave his home address out and you were wrong.
I feel like for sure he should be able to sue.
You don't think he would.
I think it won't be effective is especially because the California has the anti
slap statutes against strategic lawsuits for against public participation.
It's really strong protections for the first amendment,
especially with journalistic organization.
You have to show malice.
You have to show that he's not in the public interest.
You have to show deliberate harm and he has to show damages.
It wouldn't work.
Here's the point.
Here's the important point.
What did the Bitcoin community do with that?
They immediately said,
how can we help this man?
People said,
let's buy a model trains.
He really likes model trains.
Let's send them cash.
And some people started saying,
let's do a fundraiser.
Let's do a fundraiser.
But who's going to do the fundraiser needs?
Someone trusted in the community.
And I looked at this and I thought,
I really don't want to get involved,
but this guy really deserves a break.
So I started a fundraiser.
Two days after this story broke,
I created an address which started with one Dorian,
a bit coin address of Vanity address.
And I said,
let's do a fundraiser for Dorian.
And it's six hours.
That morning we raised 30 bitcoin and seen thousand dollars and over and over a
period of one month we raised a 50 bitcoin 47.
Some are for Dorian.
Um,
that's incredible.
He could have now and it really started pouring in like exactly what you saw
just now on air.
What is it?
What's the address?
Okay,
yeah,
let's uh,
let's post it on air.
He,
I'm sure he would like some more.
Um,
as I got the video pulled up,
if you wanted to watch play the video,
so let me just,
let me just say what we did next,
which is,
um,
we need to make sure we got this money to the right person.
And I couldn't do that because a lot of people came to me and they said,
I'm Dorian giving the money.
No,
you're not.
Not that stupid.
The only thing I knew is what he looked like.
So I visited him at his home yesterday and completed my part of the deal and
gave him the fund raiser.
And I haven't announced this.
Yes,
I just did a posting with the video and he made a little video for us.
So I'd like to play that video is for the bitcoin community.
And while you're doing that,
I'll pull up his address.
You can do some more donations.
Beautiful.
Or we can do as many as you want to tell that it about
it hasn't been edited yet.
It's still in process.
The editing
bitcoin community.
Thank you very much for your support throughout this whole deal that I'm still
fighting.
And um,
I would like you to see this,
this magazine,
which came out in April,
it will be a no,
actually march 14 issue this year.
The bitcoin fates,
the mystery man behind equipped all currency.
And I'm not Satoshi Nakamoto as portrayed as a creator.
My name is Dorian Satoshi Nakamoto.
And of course if I was a real creator,
I will never use my real name.
So from that point of view,
I'm sure you guys would know that's a toy she knocked.
Komodo is not me,
but a Leah thinks so and use sweets it so,
but it's not true.
Okay.
I received the bitcoin account from Andreas
and I'm very thankful for you all these people in us,
Europe and Asia and Africa and South America who supported me throughout.
Thank you very much.
I want to hug,
hug you
2000 or few who donated and I'm very happy.
Each one gives me a tech.
He might heart.
Thank you very much.
And I would like to further state that I'll be one of the big coin user,
bitcoin community person who would contribute even if it's a little part of this
world for good of humankind as Andrea [inaudible] and many other few Endover to
make the world a little bit better for everybody,
especially for poor people.
Thank you.
And I'll keep my bitcoin account
for many,
many years and hopefully
I can also contribute as you that to me.
Thank you.
That's so cool.
I love,
I love his sentiment.
I love what he just said.
You know,
you could tell that's not a,
I wasn't a canned speech that that guy was really touched.
Yes,
it was a,
he is really sweet,
really sweet person and this wasn't fair what happened to him,
but the bitcoin community came through with a really great fundraiser that will
have a material impact on this person's life.
That's so cool.
And do ops some of the damage that was caused by irresponsible journalism.
And I,
I can tell you,
I mean I spend three hours with him.
He is not the tuition to come out of the creative bitcoin.
No question about it.
I mean,
just setting up his Internet connection was a huge struggle.
Is that his a bitcoin address,
Brian?
Yeah.
Um,
can you text me that so I could put it online or email me that so I to put it
online,
I female both sent it to me.
Nope,
please send it to me and I'll throw it up on Twitter right now too.
Um,
with the story explaining to everybody who this gentleman is and what went
wrong,
that's sad that they decided to go ahead and print that story with no,
no substantiation.
They're still sticking by the story.
They still saying we got the right person.
How can they do that?
And,
and it's so obvious to everyone who's got half a brain,
what does this gentleman do?
He's retired.
He used to be involved in,
I mean,
I don't want to,
I don't want
to intrude in his life any,
any further.
He just wants to be left alone.
Uh,
and by the way,
he now has access to this fundraiser so he can,
he can use this money.
But um,
yeah,
I mean they,
they,
they basically intruded into his life and violated his privacy and most
importantly handled his personal information irresponsibly.
Um,
but in the end,
the bitcoin community came through with generosity and grace and charity.
And that's the,
that's really the big thing about bitcoin is,
is so much charity going on in this space.
I think that's beautiful.
And it is cool at the bid corn community came through.
But what drives me crazy is that this long established journalism outlet would
be so irresponsible.
Not that long established.
This is being purchased is the name has been purchased by new management,
has nothing to do with the previous management.
Oh,
Newsweek,
raw.
This is completely new.
People running under the same brand.
When did this and now you know exactly what kind of quality journalism they put
out,
which is yellow trash.
So they're just trying to make money.
They're just trying to sell magazines at whatever cost.
Do you think they knew that this guy,
do you think they are sticking by the story because he can't prove it?
Do you think they're just trying to not be responsible for their actions or not
be financially responsible for any damages that
he might've suffered?
They make money the way they make money,
they make click see the way,
the more controversy around it,
it doesn't really matter at this point.
That's very disappointing.
So this is a new thing.
People that have bought Newsweek,
this is fairly new.
Yeah.
This came out on the 14th of March.
I mean the,
the purchase of Newsweek.
Yes.
This is their,
this is their launch edition.
This is what they launched with.
You can't,
you can't go backwards on your first issue of a nuance because that would make
you,
you're like,
oh yeah,
we suck.
Now.
Their first edition was an absolute stinker.
Oh,
what?
A bunch of Dick bags.
So
gross.
I'll never buy a Newsweek.
I'll tell you that.
Not you can't do that.
Can't do.
You can't push a guy's fucking home address out there.
And pictures of them will answer dory and Yakamoto when his lawyers writes us
what?
I like that guy.
Fuck you.
You gotta know,
man.
You've got to really be sure you can't just accuse a guy,
especially in the midst of all this chaos with the Mt Gox collapse
and the very real physical danger that is implied by first saying that someone
has a lot of money,
which he doesn't.
And uh,
inviting all of the crazies to visit his address by publishing it
insane amounts of money,
right?
Like $9 million or something,
something fucking crazy like that.
Not even need billion dollars.
What was it?
The real subtle,
she could be a controlling up to $500 million in bitcoin a current price.
So you can hold it.
You mean he might have that much a million pick one?
He might have himself.
He might have a million bitcoin.
Yes.
That's,
that's the estimate that Satoshi Nakamoto has a million bitcoin.
Okay.
But is he real?
Is there a Satoshi Nakamoto?
Is there a guy,
let's say,
let's call Mr x.
There is a real Mr x.
Well,
I,
I'd like to think that,
um,
well she is real.
She okay.
Hey,
why not?
Why not?
Who knows?
She has a Ba.
I usually say she's have to one of the conferences.
So make sure you treat all the ladies right.
Because one of them might be Sitoshi.
Could you imagine?
Yeah.
Imagine if Satoshi was just a really smart who's growing?
I mean the,
the,
you know,
you can say it's a pseudonym,
so it could be male,
female,
doesn't matter.
It could be several folks.
Right.
And I think the most likely explanation is that it was a group of researchers,
but it doesn't matter.
It doesn't matter what it is.
That group of researchers,
that group of researchers is in control of $500 million worth of Bitcoin,
potentially potentially in control because we don't know what's happened with
the keys.
None of it has been moved.
None of it has been touched.
So it's just sitting there.
It's just sitting there.
We'll test it.
We'll be the first car that you could buy with bitcoin.
I don't know.
He probably can already.
I think they,
there's some dealers are selling a bunch of cars for bitcoin.
I wouldn't be surprised that they're selling cars for bitcoin.
A bunch of lumbar kidneys have been sold for bitcoin already.
People are buying apartments and property and planes and then of course in trade
it in for money.
So you can pretty much buy anything with bitcoins with an exchange.
And Virgin Galactic,
um,
cells,
uh,
seats on their flights to space of a bitcoin and they've sold seven already.
All it's happening.
People are going to space with bitcoin
allegedly going to space.
They might just get launched on the end of a bomb.
That motherfucker's going to have to fly for a long time before daddy goes to
space.
I'm so not interested in being an early adopter of the fucking spaceship.
I'm not really space either coins and Neil degrasse Tyson,
he thinks it's kind of do it.
Yeah,
he thinks it's kind of a goof to spend $100,000 to go like a little higher than
a plane and look down and then dropped back down again.
Well you do go into zero G.
Yeah,
and so I think it's interesting because it's that reusable reentry capability,
which is revolutionary in the way they've done it is very visionary approach
real time.
Well,
no doubt about it.
Richard Branson's a bad mother fucker.
No,
a no argument there.
I just think until you can go to the moon,
you can go fuck yourself.
That's what I think.
Or until you can go zoom around a few con,
you know,
hang out there for a day,
sit a luxury suite on a top of the earth and look down.
You can only go there for like a minute and then you got to come flying back
down again.
Right?
Isn't that the idea behind that?
Yeah,
I would agree.
The ultimate goal is to the,
to the moon.
Alice
having nice,
I like hotel.
They're like,
I didn't like a really nice hotel that you can stay out for a weekend.
Some Moon,
hotel,
g zero g swimming pools,
zero g sex.
How about that?
Coming here?
Facials,
zero g squirt.
She's ducks like she's no matrix.
You would have a,
well,
I guess it would still propel.
It would probably go on for ever and if you could stick your dick outside of the
spaceship and just shoot,
went into space,
it would just take off forever,
but it'd be frozen instantly.
Girls on a rag and being on your bed.
It's floating around in your whole entire room.
You're not going to discuss what if she squirts?
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
You don't want to upset.
This is the Joe Rogan experience podcast.
That's how we do things over here.
I'm sorry.
I mean a,
we're going to help you promote bitcoin,
but we're not going to change the format.
No,
no.
I love loving it.
No worries.
Um,
so Lamborghini doesn't take it.
It's like a third party thing.
Is that how you close?
Who are selling you ships that are taking that crazy accepting bitcoin?
Well,
yeah.
How crazy is the risk?
Listen,
you'd get a lot of a lot of publicity and marketing and then you take the big
coin and you convert it the same day to us dollar.
So you don't get any exchange rate risk.
And what's the difference?
Nothing.
Good point.
It's a very good point.
A lot of merchants are doing,
I kind of see it,
but man,
you,
you would,
I would put a tap on it.
You know,
if it was my dealership,
I'd say we're allowed to sell one a month with bitcoin.
Everything else has to be with good old American dollars back by blood and
eagles
fucking,
you can't just bank the whole thing on these,
these weird digital currencies.
I bet.
I'm going to be sending Justin wren 1000 bucks by the end of this day.
Yeah,
I might be a lot more than that.
I don't know.
I'm going to have to decipher it.
I'm going to need your help.
Yeah.
After this podcast is over,
we're going to have to go over how much I need to write a check for.
What?
I'm going to leave the money in there though.
So if you keep sending it to him,
he'll kill,
keep getting money.
Um,
what else has happened in the last two and a half months besides these?
A really fantastic innovations that,
uh,
that you're excited about?
Well,
there's,
there's the whole environment,
which is weird in terms of media,
on regulation.
It's been good news,
bad news,
good news,
trying to stay.
You were talking about China's spending it,
not bending it.
Russia's banning it and not battling it.
Vietnam spending it and not panning it.
And this is really funny because of course the countries in which these iron
fist bands are happening at the countries where the rule of law is least
respected.
So true.
Right,
right.
So it's like boots and bandits.
Well,
you know what?
Hard dollars were bands in the 80s,
in,
in Russia.
You couldn't,
you were not allowed to have foreign currency,
hard currency throughout the Soviet Union.
Um,
it was banned from very,
very seriously band,
I guess,
who started stuffing their suitcases with hard dollars
first,
the politburo.
Oh,
of course.
And then the army generals and then the cops and then all of the people who are
in those countries are above the law.
And then the people who were below the law then bribes that people who are above
the law in dollars of course,
um,
to also hold dollars and the whole thing becomes a mockery.
Puente is like a gigantic Russian version of John Gotti.
You know,
he really is like,
you remember how God,
he was like so flamboyant about the fact that he was the head of the mob.
Like there was the heads of the mom before God.
He were like real secretive.
There was that Guy Vincent the chin,
good Janti or however you say his name,
who would walk around the neighborhood pretending to be crazy.
He would wear a bathrobe and slippers and you,
they wouldn't even like say his name because they,
he told everybody that everything was being tapped all the time.
So don't ever say my name when you're talking about me.
Point point to your chin.
So people would just like go and you know,
it's not going to take that he's going to,
you know,
it's going to want to do something for our friends.
So you know,
that's a good idea.
They had pointed a Chin because his name is Vincent the chin,
good Janti or gigante or whatever the hell it was.
But um,
but then God,
he came along and just wearing fucking $10,000 suits and you know,
it was an obvious mobster and had obvious mobsters with a,
when there was public kits and all this crazy shit and everybody loved him
because he was the face of the mob.
This Putin guy is sort of like that in a way.
But on I'll crazier scale because he's running a whole country.
I mean he's essentially just grabbed the whole country
and not just that,
here's the little secret.
I think that the thing that most people miss is the elephant in the room.
And that's Gazprom.
That's what natural gas,
natural gas Gazprom.
So basically they've nationalized the gas industry.
The gas industry then supplies a natural gas,
which is,
uh,
one of the ways that we've avoided the impact of peak oil and energy
constriction that is killing worldwide economies right now because oil's gotten
vastly expensive,
but cast Scott cheaper because of fracking and other things.
And Gazprom produces most of the gas in the world.
So much so that they supply all of Europe with natural gas and they supply them
through pipelines that go through which country Africanize the Ukraine and
Afghanistan and various other places.
But the line of pipelines of gas are the hot spots of war and civil war and the
occupation all across eastern Europe.
And right now there's this huge power play going on,
uh,
around the Ukraine.
And a lot of that has to do with a routes of gas.
And it's,
and it's a massive geopolitical power play between a world powers.
And Putin can basically say,
we just doubled the price of gas in the Ukraine,
which is exactly what they did.
I think they quadrupled in fact,
which plunged the country into a recession.
And then they said to Europe,
you know,
you don't threaten us with sanctions,
we're going to turn off your gas.
And if you do,
all of you are going into recession because that's the only form of cheap energy
you have.
Oh,
we got to go into world war three
is that it seems like some weird shit is happening.
Japan is upping its military now.
It's navy is getting larger and larger by the day.
And uh,
they're,
they're changing their whole policies as far as how they deal with other
countries because China is encroaching on a lot of these islands that Japan has
been controlling.
And it seems to me like more and more every day the powers are moving into
position to dominate portions of the world.
And it just seems,
it seems like some shit is about to happen.
The era of cheap energy is over and the world has to reshuffle to accept that
fact.
Uh,
cheap peak oil changes everything.
You can't sustain the same,
uh,
consumerists behavior in developed countries and that together with climate
change,
it's a,
it's a combination.
The creates upheaval all around the world and at the same time you have the
world's worst currency crisis in three generations and we are currently living
through the most significant currency crisis with dozens of countries suffering
from hyperinflation with our currency is about to collapse,
um,
Europe and the euro hanging from a threads,
the British sterling hanging from a thread and the US dollar going crazy with
printing and into that environment.
You now have bitcoin.
It's a really interesting time to live in because there's so much change going
on as an escort service accepts bit coin.
Yes.
He's very excited.
Now did you put up your bitcoin address?
Yeah,
you should say that.
I'll donate it all to Justin ran.
You'll didn't donate it all to hookers,
corvette to all Lexis.
So I'm glad that we didn't get very far with a conversation about empowering the
poor and discussions about bitcoin can do before Brian Duff,
an escort site.
It's nice to empower the poor.
But guess who else was poor hookers?
Yeah.
Um,
no,
I see what you're saying.
The best way to do it.
One thing that you can say about that particular cases that um,
women in those professions are exploited by,
by the men.
You can't do that.
The kid just sneakily post that,
put it on your Twitter.
You fuck put it on your Twitter and I'll retweet it.
Okay.
Sorry.
Yeah,
you're right.
They're exploited.
All the money,
all the money flows to the men who control and exploit them.
Right?
And so bitcoin is being used already in,
in many cases for women to be able to keep control of their money so he can't be
stolen pimps and exploited,
exploited boyfriends and,
and a hustler is in all of the other criminals who are around them who take
advantage of these women.
So actually it is quite an empowering technology even in that particular
occupation or related occupations.
I was having this conversation on Twitter and people with teasing me.
So I did a,
uh,
a satirical shot.
I said,
look,
I'm going to start at the same business.
I'm going to post the a half naked shot of me and I'm going to make people pay
me to stop because I'm a pasty middle aged male and nobody wants to see that
shit and I'm going to donate all of the money that I raised and now it's it.
It went viral on Twitter.
It's me doing a Miley Cyrus impersonation of looking at hammer.
It's just like from hero,
but it's a smart move.
But I raised and,
and I'm pretty proud of that photo because I ridiculed and exploited myself and
raise $600,
which I donated to the rape and incest national network,
which is a network that helps exploited women,
uh,
extract themselves from the abusive environments and gives them shelter.
And essentially it's like a underground railroad to get them away from people
who are exploiting them or abusing them badly.
That's awesome.
You know,
one of the things that we've talked about on this podcast before and I think
applies here is that there's,
there's a certain morality to a lot of these big tech companies and to tech in
general that I don't think exists in a lot of other industries and that there's
a lot of companies that are coming up now.
Tech companies that are founded by very intelligent,
very educated people also have pretty strong ethics and I think that's rare for,
for businesses to have like a,
like a fairly established trend of ethical consideration involved in their
business practices.
And one of the reasons why I think is because no one understands transparency
more than people that are really into the Internet.
No one understands the implications or the ramifications rather of your actions,
whether positive or negative more than people that are,
that are on the Internet.
What are you looking up at you?
I'm waiting for red vans.
Pull up some embarrassing photos and moment to do that.
You have that same photos then will the fe,
the picture that he was talking about?
Oh No,
no,
no.
Don't,
don't.
No,
I'll think.
See he's being really nice to me today.
Thank you.
It was nice to see buddy.
He's always nice.
Believe me,
I did read though,
I was doing some research about the Ip of thing cause that's the only thing I
did have.
But there is some people saying that you could find the Ip if you were devoted
to it.
Like meaning if I really wanted to find out what your IPO address it's using the
bitcoin currency,
I could just probably figure it out if I was really detailed about it.
No you can't.
Um,
I think that's entirely wrong because um,
if you were doing transactions,
those transactions would be communicated across the peer to peer network,
kind of like bittorrent and they spread through that peer to peer network in
such a way that you can't even with the transaction happened.
But in your particular case you're not even doing any transactions.
Um,
there is no way to associate a bit coin address to an Ip address unless you're
monitoring that person specific communication.
So for example,
if someone's monitoring your laptop,
they can figure out your connected to that Ip address.
But guess what?
If they're monitoring your laptop,
they already know that it's not so hard.
But just monitoring the bitcoin network,
you cannot associate addresses to bitcoin addresses to Ip addresses.
I'm putting up Dorian Nakamoto goes,
I,
I retweeted yours,
Brian and,
uh,
contribute to Dorian Nakamoto
too.
How do you spell Dorian?
Dorian?
T.
O r I a n and knock a moto.
Yes,
exactly.
How you see you hear it.
Do you know who damn Kaminsky is a chief scientist for d k h he wrote in 2011
that you could,
uh,
do that.
And that's what I
was basing my findings on.
He said that unless you're a very careful in the way you use bitcoin and you
have the technical know how to use it with other anonymizing to technologies
like tour or ITP,
you should assume that a persistent motivated attacker will be able to associate
your IP address with your bitcoin transactions
and Black Hawk black hat 2011 talk.
Yeah.
And the,
and that's not their,
they're not associating the Ip address,
the bitcoin address because it's in the network.
While we're talking about there is a determined attacker who's conducting
surveillance of the entire network and has the resources to track down what's
happening.
And so people say that bitcoin is anonymous,
but in fact it's not.
It's pseudonymous and loosely synonymous.
That means that if you conduct activities with Bitcoin that associate your
bitcoin address to other things,
like for example,
you use it to buy something and then that's something gets shipped to your home.
Well now you tied that bitcoin address to your physical address,
right?
Or um,
I have a donation address that I publish.
Everybody knows that's my address.
Now if I take money from that bit coin address,
which my donation address and I move it into my wallets that I use to spend on
other things.
Now everyone can track that step by step.
No,
well that's my wallet and then track everything that goes out of that wallet.
So I have to take some basic privacy precautions to protect against that.
Now would there be cause like it's kind of like an account number,
I guess like at a bank,
like you said.
Now,
is there technology or is or hackers that can take knowing your,
your account number and recreate it in a program that makes it seem like you are
that person and uh,
like transfer money out of that account?
No,
because the,
the address itself is essentially one part of an encryption key.
And
the other part of the pair of keys,
the private key is the thing you have on your phone wallet,
right?
That's the secret.
That's the thing that allows you to sign transactions.
And the whole basis of cryptography of encryption systems is that you can't go
from the public address to the private secret.
You can't go backwards.
You can go from the private secret,
you can recreate the public address,
but you can't go backwards.
That is the whole basis that technology is the same technology that's used to
secure a bank networks.
It's the same technology that's used to secure Tomahawk missiles.
It's the same technology that's used to secure everything.
And so,
um,
you can rest assured that the cryptography at the core of bitcoin is solid
because it's used across all of the other industries.
Be better off like,
hey,
when a charged my phone on your laptop and then you just download their phone
and then re upload it on your phone and then you have their wallet and you
shave.
So that's why you have masterminds blueprint,
so that's why you have a password on that application so that if he,
if you steal the data,
if that up
application,
it's encrypted,
then you can't see the keys that are underneath.
Right.
That's what the pin number and password do and I have a secondary password.
Those also prevents from spending specifically for spending.
All right,
man,
you want to do this again in three months?
I'd love to.
It's about three years in bitcoin time.
A lot of things will change.
Well that really appreciate every opportunity.
I appreciate it as well.
I mean you were very,
very informative and we've never be this educated about this stuff.
If it wasn't for you and I think you'd do a huge service to not just the tech
community with this,
but just the general population,
giving them an understanding of what this is all about.
There's so much misinformation and confusion about it.
I mean,
we had just Brian and I to fucking dunces sitting there staring at each other,
trying to figure out what it was before you came along.
So it helps us tremendously.
And I think,
uh,
what you're doing is,
is it's,
it's brave.
I mean,
you,
you're getting paid through bitcoin.
It's noble.
You have,
you're using it in great ways.
I love what you did for Nakamoto.
I just posted his,
a bitcoin address along with an article explaining what went wrong and how he's
not that guy.
And,
um,
I just think it's cool as fuck,
man.
And uh,
I'm honored that you're a part of this.
Oh,
thank you so much.
And,
and what I'm doing is I'm just expressing my enthusiasm for this space,
but let me tell you a couple of quick stories about why this was awesome.
Uh,
after the first Joe Rogan experience,
um,
suddenly I had people everywhere coming and telling me that they got into
bitcoin because of that first show,
because they finally were able to understand it.
And I'll give you two stories.
A month ago,
I was in a Houston airport.
I was sitting down having lunch.
I was in transits between flights and I'm sitting there and someone sees my
watch and they go,
oh,
is that the new pebble?
I'm like,
yeah,
it is.
You could write applications and what kind of applications as well.
The application I have on here,
which is pretty cool is I can check bitcoin addresses and like bitcoin
addresses.
Oh,
that's pretty cool.
Yeah.
I said,
you heard a bitcoin?
Yeah,
I've heard of bitcoin.
Hey,
hang on a second.
Is Your name and your absence and all pillows are like,
yeah.
Were you on Joe Rogan?
You're the reason I bought bitcoin.
I got involved in bitcoin after seeing that episodes and I was just blown away.
I mean,
this is like I'm sitting down for lunch and a transit area in a restaurant.
I'm not used to being recognized that way,
so the better part.
Monday,
yesterday I landed at lax.
I go to enterprise,
rent a car to pick up my car.
I get into my car,
I drive to the exit.
I had my driver's license and rental tickets to the booth guy at the exit and he
takes a look at it and he goes,
were you in the Joe Rogan experience?
Like yeah,
you're the reason I bought bitcoin.
You're the reason I got into bitcoin and I follow you on Twitter in the Joe
Rogan experience got me into bitcoin.
This story has repeated a thousand times for me and not just from 15,000 people
on Twitter who started following me after the first show.
Uh,
and who got excited about bitcoin but complete strangers in the street and
things like that.
And yes,
I get my share of crazies and stalkers and all of that.
And it doesn't matter because the vast majority is such a positive experience.
And what everyone says is that you asked really great questions.
You asked the every man questions the question,
everybody wanted to ask the simple questions that to try to understand and grasp
this topic.
And for me that was a wonderful opportunity.
So thank you.
Thank you.
Listen.
The beautiful thing about having a podcast is nobody brings anything on the show
that I'm not interested in.
It's not like a network demands that I interviewed this guy who was on this
sitcom or something like that.
If I'm talking to somebody,
it's because the subject is fascinating and that it's actually something I'm
truly interested in and that's not having all those sort of like ladders and
steps that you have to climb to put content out is really what it's all about in
in a way that sort of mirrors what bitcoin is.
It's cutting out all the steps that are unnecessary between human beings
interacting with each other,
whether it's exchanging money or exchanging ideas and information.
It's essentially,
it's a lot of it is along the same trend and it's all along the same lines.
Yeah.
Let's get you,
let's get you selling your products on the,
on it and the other sites with a well
make it happen with bitcoin.
[inaudible] dot com yeah.
Oh,
by the way,
higher primate.com has new shit in a higher priority.
We just restocked it.
We have a bunch of new t shirts in now and we have a j r e t shirts that are the
logo that's on my,
um,
on my Twitter page.
That's the newest one,
both in Colorado and black.
All right,
we're out of here.
He fucks a,
we'll see you guys next week.
Follow Andreas on to Napo lists on Twitter please.
And My podcast.
Let's talk bitcoin.com.
Yes.
And is it on,
um,
is that on iTunes as well as episodes?
Do you have out there a hundred?
We just celebrated 100 episodes.
Wheezes a hundred episodes a one.
You're like,
I can't get enough bitcoin information.
Yes,
you can,
motherfucker.
Yes,
you can.
You can get a hundred Goddamn podcasts on it.
A N t o n o p.
That is his Twitter handle.
A n.
T.
O.
N.
P.
Thank you sir.
Thank you.
We're honored to have you on every three months,
right?
Three months,
three years in bitcoin.
All right.
And uh,
we will see you guys next week.
Next week.
Um,
I've got a lot of great guests.
I've got Steve Maxwell,
world famous strength and conditioning coach.
She's on Monday.
David Towl,
Greg Fitzsimmons and a.
Then next Friday night I'm at the Lobero theater in Santa Barbara With Mad
Flavor,
Aka Joey Coco Diaz almost sold out.
So don't be slipping.
Santa Barbara.
Barbara.
Okay.
Uh,
thanks to our sponsors.
Thanks to today was a legal zoom legal zoom.com.
Did you have something to say?
The three M I was just gonna say this Friday I'll be in Tucson with same AAA and
then Saturday and Phoenix.
Which Sam Aaa.
Oh,
beautiful.
squad.tv for ticks.
Oh,
beautiful.
What do you guys do?
And you're doing um,
uh,
like clubs out there?
Yeah,
we're good players.
Hotel Congress in Tucson,
which is really bad as like,
Whoa,
hotel.
That's hot.
I'm sorry.
I heard it's bad ass.
Just isn't Doug live near there?
Yes,
you could drive there.
Um,
not,
not that close,
but like an hour and a half shot like that.
It's cool.
Is Tucson,
is that place?
Uh,
how many,
how many is that seat?
I want to say it's like 150,
200.
I don't know.
And they do shows on a regular,
uh,
yeah.
Yeah.
Dope.
All right.
A dollar shave,
dollar shave club.com.
Go to dollar shave club.com.
Forward Slash Rogen.
That's dollar shave.com.
Dollar Shave Club,
dollar shave club.com.
Forward Slash Rogen.
Thanks.
Also to legal zoom.
Go to legal zoom.com and enter the code word Rogan in the referral box at
checkout for more savings.
Thanks also to Onnit.
Got Co,
excuse me.
Thanks to onnit.com oh and,
and it,
uh,
go to on it.
Use the Codeword Rogan.
Save 10% off any and all seven events.
Okay.
Uh,
we'll see you guys next week.
Much love big kiss.